[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
of the January 6 Insurrection hearings
from the January 6 select committee on
Capitol Hill I am Tony Michaels with the
Tony Michaels podcast here to host the
special coverage of the Midas touch
Network for this hearing we are under
the assumption that this is going to be
the final uh public hearing where they
are going to present evidence we're not
sure if they're going to have any other
kind of closing hearings but from what
we understand at this point this may be
day nine may be the final hearing that
we have here from the January 6 select
committee as always here on the Midas
touch Network don't forget to subscribe
here on the YouTube channel why you're
here you're not going to want to miss
out on all the analysis here from the
Midas touch Network also go over and do
me a favor uh subscribe to D Tony
Michaels podcast Channel on YouTube that
would help me out a lot you can download
all these episodes now these will be put
up on directory samples Spotify Google
and to download as well don't forget to
do that and support Independent Media
this is super important in this day and
age so go over to Midas Touch Network's
patreon and check out their patreon they
have several different levels to join
their patreon and support
Independent Media
as we bring this to you you know we
bring you panels and commentary before
the hearing starts the hearing will
start at the top of the next hour
the January 6 select committee has been
very prompt in their scheduling outside
some technical issues so they should be
very prompt at the top of the hour but
we're going to bring you
some very great commentary from the
Midas touch Network some legal analysis
some political analysis and of course
some great you know maybe Chuckles from
me and my co-host Dave Sanchez here on
the Midas touch Network today so stay
tuned for the entire hearing we will
play it in its entirety we'll also have
commentary on the other side of the
hearing we're going to hear from folks
like Lee McGowan the politics girl from
politicsgirl podcast Dr Rachel
bidikoffer and our panel will also be
joining us and I think we'll probably
hear from the my zealous Brothers the
mind is touch podcast at some point
during this coverage so stay tuned for
the entirety of the coverage beforehand
the during and the commentary after we
also have the the great minus money
favorite Texas Paul of the site I want
to forget Texas Paul he was fired up on
our show the other day and so hopefully
he'll be fired up today about this
hearing I know he will be on Texas Paul
always bring brings the heat but I want
to go first to
add
a great lawyer and legal analyst for
legal AF Michael pop Michael popock I
really this is going to be a Crossroads
here and we were talking about it this
morning how are you sir
I'm doing great I don't know if I'm
going to bring the heat but I'm going to
try to bring the light well that's great
that's great well you know I I want to
ask you because we were talking this
morning as we were preparing for the
coverage here and there seems to be a
Crossroads between an actual criminal
trial and the political hearings today
on Capitol Hill it's almost like they're
intersecting because the judge in the
criminal trial of The Oath Keepers is
um I forget the exact words but there's
he's strongly encouraging those jurors
no he's admonishing he's admonishing and
instructing there you go there you go
that that's it and he is so so you you
were going to give more of a legal on
take on this I'm sure but from what I
see from the non-legal view of this is
that the judge is being very careful
here that the jurors are not tainted by
what we are going to hear in the January
6th select hearings today because we
have heard that it's going to have to do
with Secret Service Communications on
the day of January 6 but also this film
uh this this Danish documentary film on
Roger Stone we're going to see some of
that it also appears that they're going
to really tie Trump
um
his ankles around January 6 and the coup
attempt now why would the judge be so
adamant and you say a moment I think
that's the legal term but why would he
be so adamant to make sure that these
jurors do not have any whiff of this
coverage
well thanks Tony on Capitol Hill today
we're going to see session nine of the
John 6 committee
it is not a criminal trial we'd like it
to be they're going to be presenting
evidence that's going to be similar to
what the Department of Justice is going
to present ultimately hopefully against
the very top Apex people apex predators
like Donald Trump who are responsible
for what happened on Jan 6 and
everything leading up to it and the plan
to cling to power to stop the peaceful
transfer of power and for Trump to
remain in power that's what's going on
in in the uh in the chambers of Congress
today but right up the street at a
federal courthouse there are defendants
under our form of of justice that whose
Liberty
is at stake and we all want them of
course convicted if that's what the
evidence so shows but there is a jury
who is charged in our system of
jurisprudence and Justice who's tasked
with finding
um finding people guilty or innocent and
if guilty sending them to jail and so
the federal judge judge Mata
has a very large task here
he's already instructed the jury at the
very beginning and will instruct them at
the end before they deliberate that
nothing from outside of the Jury Room
can interfere with their decision making
can impact their decision making no
preconceived notions no independent
research that they did or shouldn't be
doing no news reports no media reports
no family conversations nothing it's
only what is presented by the Department
of Justice on their burden of proof to
find Beyond a reasonable doubt that
these Oath Keepers are guilty of
seditious conspiracy and other charges
and that's it and that has to be
preserved and I want it and we all on
the Midas touch Network want
our system of justice to be preserved so
the judge mindful
as he has before
because there's been other intersections
between one of the prior eight sessions
and other cases going on around town
against
um gen stick's insurrectionist but today
in particular it becomes as you said a
weird Cosmic intersection it becomes
really acute because on the very day
that the Jan 6 committee we've been told
by reporting is going to focus on Donald
Trump's State of Mind before the
election during the election after the
election on Jan 6 and Beyond and why he
is culpable for what happened with
perpetuating the the big lie that he won
the election all the way through the
violence and the Insurrection that Siege
the capital on Jan 6 and Beyond
with using 1.5 million pieces of
evidence obtained finally from the
Secret Service we're finally going to
hear that side of the story but there's
going to be a focus today we believe on
Roger Stone who has become the dirty
trickster for Donald Trump from the very
beginning the architect of all the dirty
tricks he became
to use a historical reference the Roy
Cohen that Donald Trump always had by
his side another dirty trickster of a
lawyer in New York who passed away and
was replaced by Roger Stone
who started his career working for the
committee to re-elect the president the
president being Richard Nixon being
involved with Watergate all the way to
here and there is documentary footage as
you've alluded to Tony that bears out
what's going on down the street and
judge made his courtroom it's the Danish
documentary footage of Roger Stone with
The Oath Keepers with the proud boys and
his comments which seemed to be
um what Donald Trump wants him to say
his comments of to paraphrase
before the election [ __ ] the voting [ __ ]
the election let's get right to the
violence that's a direct quote that's
going to be I'm sure showed today on the
Gen 6 Committee hearing
surrounded by Oath Keepers and proud
boys the very Oath Keepers and proud
boys and the or at least The Oath
Keepers who are on trial right now up
the street
and so the judge is understandably
concerned that they at their lunch break
on their cell phone that they're not
supposed to be looking at through texts
from friends or family are going to know
about the presentation being made by the
Jan 6 committee and that evidence that's
evidence for us on the Gen 6 committee
for the American public is not evidence
in the courtroom for them to consider in
fact it would be improper and and more
importantly reversible error the judge
is trying to protect the case from
having error committed that could be
used on appeal by Stuart Rhodes and The
Oath Keepers we don't want that we don't
want reversible error because some juror
you know at his lunch break took a peek
at the Gen 6 committee and saw evidence
that never ended up in the courtroom
um by the Department of Justice some of
which they will but some of which they
won't so that is the weird Cosmic
cosplay that's going on between these
two
um Chambers which have very different
purposes and very different
um rationales uh for being
um but it's all colliding today because
of the date that the um the Gen 6
committee the postponed date that the
Gen 6 committee this wouldn't have
happened two weeks ago if if hurricane
um if the hurricane Ian hadn't
interfered this would have went two
weeks ago but now they're mindful now
the Gen 6 committee couldn't care less
and they shouldn't about what's going on
in any of the courtrooms involving any
of the Trump people around the country
and there are so many of them thank god
um just just as they're not concerned
today with what got announced by Leticia
James the New York attorney general that
she's moving for the court to order the
assets Frozen by the Trump organization
to have assets put into the court
registry sufficient to pay the 250
million dollar future judgment that
doesn't enter the Gen 6 committee's
presentation nor should it life goes on
the wheels of Justice continue and they
don't take a break for anybody and so
maida judge made is doing the right
thing in his courtroom gen six
committees doing the right thing in
their presentation today and finally
Tony we get to know what was underneath
all of the covers of the uh of the
Secret Service a secret service which a
secret service which is going to be
mentioned by name or has been mentioned
by name in The Oath Keepers courtroom
because the Oath Keepers believed that
the Secret Service was on their side
that many of those people supported
Donald Trump or trumpers in Disguise
which is not what the Secret Service is
supposed to be doing they're supposed to
be politically agnostic and protect the
president and protect whoever they're
responsible for protecting not be
political
and so they're mentioned in the
courtroom even as we speak now where did
they where did The Oath Keepers get the
idea that the Secret Service was on
their side and would see them as
liberators when they came storming the
capital
one good idea Roger Stone that might be
what they reveal today right right that
Roger Stone who is also going to be uh
front and center in today's presentation
in the next 45 minutes by the Gen 6
committee and the documentarians the
Danish documentarians by the way are
going to be in they're not going to be
talking but they're going to be
apparently at the hearing
because they want to see how their film
clips are being used after the Gen 6
committee went all the way over to
Copenhagen to go look at this material
this is what they've been doing all
summer but but it's it's fascinating
since the last time you and I got
together to talk about the hearing I did
not realize until a few days ago that
they had gotten their hands on 1.5
million text messages Microsoft team
Communications and other things from the
Secret Service now there's a set of text
messages that are gone because the
Secret Service deleted them but there's
1.5 million that aren't and I think
we're going to see a nice grouping of
those as this the Jan 6 committee makes
I don't know if it's their final closing
argument but certainly this is all this
is going to be an all Trump all-trump
mental state all Trump conduct
um uh Edition uh number nine of of the
John 6 committee because they want to
show that he can't possibly say that he
did not know what was happening before
during or after Jan 6 including the
weapons that were brought in they're
going to put on evidence about that
they're going to put on evidence about
about his mental state before the
election even happened
he was talking about a steal being
stopped before there was even an
election
right so well so let me ask you let me
ask you one question because I I I find
this um this Secret Service thing very
interesting and I guess the reason why I
find this inner section or this
Crossroad today of the trial of The Oath
Keepers where like you said they're
mentioning an open court as we speak
just moments before we came to air
within the last few hours that
that yes The Oath Keepers had had
communication prior to January 6 even
um at some of the rallies that they were
budding up they were becoming you know
building relationships almost which is
like you said kind of scary that they
might have been building political
relationships my question is this with
this judge's decision to be so
um strict about what they can and cannot
see here
because the judge in this case would see
the discovery right does he know what is
going to be presented in open court
um
not yet so he doesn't know that no in in
a criminal case and usually in a civil
case too
um there is a list of exhibits that's
usually presented I think the the
government has done has done an exchange
for the other side about the exhibits
they plan to use but let's be frank the
judge may have peered over them may have
looked over them but you know he doesn't
know his role as the gatekeeper of
evidence is to make sure the jury is
presented the evidence in the right way
to make sure that the case is error-free
in terms of its presentation and that
both sides are treated fairly in that
courtroom and to make one small not
correction clarification they have
already been instructed from the
beginning of being jurors when they were
sworn in that they are not to watch the
media or get any outside information
he's just reminding them particularly
today because today yes yes because
because it's going to be on the news and
this jury is not sequestered you know
that that sequestering a jury meaning
putting them up in a hotel and giving
them dinner they rarely do do that
anymore I mean it's great for movies and
television you know to put a jury you
know Law and Order may do it but in real
life it's it's a real hardship on the
jurors judges hate it unless they really
have no choice because they're worried
so this jury's going home at five
o'clock and they're and he can't tell
them not to look at their cell phones so
they're looking at their cell phones
he's they're not supposed to go and see
today's coverage they're not supposed to
go see what you did today or what Midas
media Network did today in the
commentary they're not supposed to see
any of that and um
and if there's serious repercussions if
they do and they bring it into the room
and it influences their decision making
so he's got to be very Mindful and you
know the defense is looking for any you
know they're writing down every day
possible Appel appeal issues
right um well you know I think I think
this crossroad that we have between the
criminal trial of The Oath Keepers and
today what is going to be shown to the
American people as Discovery as it would
be known in a criminal trial but today
uh evidence shown as evidence in the
bare fact so uh Michael beobach thank
you very much for for joining us
um I appreciate uh always as always the
the analysis about courtrooms I know you
know them all do well thank you Mr Mr
popoc from legal aid Mr Michael yes
thank you very much everyone go follow
legal AF and download every single
episode Wednesdays and Saturdays thank
you Michael pobach we'll talk to you
soon my friend I want to bring in one of
the mightiest Mighty favorites but
before I do I want to remind you again
you can join the patreon a support
Independent Media just as Michael popock
said it's very important so you can go
to patreon.com mydistouch and you can
see all their levels of patronage there
support into dependent media and I I
would be derelict at my duty to Jordy if
I did not show the November shirts he
wanted me to make sure that you guys got
a chance to see the November shirts were
coming up on an election November row
row row your vote store not Midas
touch.com
store.industouch.com also if you'd like
to support the Tony Michaels podcast we
have some hot merch on our side go to
store.thetonymichaels.com we have these
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
it is our saying it is our motto over at
our podcast the Tony Michaels we also
have some great hoodies there as well so
please go go follow us on YouTube and
subscribe to our channel the Tony
Michaels podcast as I'm joined by the
Midas Mighty favorite
and he brings the heat he brought the
Heat this week on our show holy moly the
the clips from this conversation was
absolutely running around the internet
um and you know him all too well here on
the Midas Dutch Network Texas Paul how
are you this morning my friend I'm
wonderful I am wonderful it doesn't get
much better well it doesn't get much
better I'm actually
I'm actually very excited about this one
of the things that well first let me
make a plug for legal AF I have to tell
you those got Karen agnifolo uh Michael
popock and of course Ben Marcellus take
the most complex legal issues like
everything going on with Trump and they
dumb it down to the point they did even
even an old hillbilly like me can
understand it so
folks if you like Law and Order if you
like anything like that
do you need to watch that podcast
because they do they they really do they
take it you know this this type of
motion was filed and they well that's
what this means you know I mean they
break it down for you
it's a fantastic it's a fantastic
podcast and I just gotta give Michael
popock his props because you know a lot
of complex stuff is going on these days
and you're going to hear a lot of things
in the hearing today uh and they're
going to try to bring it down to
everybody's level so everybody can
understand it and those guys are the
best at it well you know I very
interesting that you uh bring up the
legal part but I want to know about the
politics of it because you're always
keeping track of the politics here
um what do you see about this this
documentary footage that we may see
today I mean they are saying we're going
to hear see Communications you know we
really don't know what they're going to
show us here but we do know that Roger
Stone is not going to have a good day so
what do you expect
um from the from Roger Stone's end of
the um what may be him incriminating
himself right in front of cameras in
this documentary film
Roger Stones like a serial killer they
always want to get caught
he wants everyone to know what he did
that he is his ass is in a crack and he
knows it but he put it there himself
he's he cannot shut up he cannot quit
acting like a tough guy he can't you
know he's not a real criminal he's not
real criminals keep everything on the
down low Roger wants everybody to look
at Roger and he's not walking out of
this he knows he's not walking at us and
I I'll be honest with you he doesn't
want to to me the more interesting thing
to watch is is what we're going to hear
from you know we're going to see some
tape testimony from I understand Mike
Pompeo mnuchin and Elaine Chao
um
man I really want to know what Elaine
child is going to say
you know Donald Trump threatened her
husband's life let's see how that that
that
figures into the mix and as far as the
Secret Service Communications those are
incredibly important because
you don't change Tigers don't change
their stripes they don't they can delete
all the emails from the day and think
that they've covered their ass
but they were talking before that day
they were talking before January 6th
their Communications
foreshadow exactly what they were going
to do and it there I am in extremely
excited to hear that they were able to
get as much data as they were
I think we're back uh sorry about that
uh I'm not sure what happened Texas Paul
are you still here with us yeah I'm
still I had to pop back in but I don't I
got got ejected
I'm not sure I'm not sure I think uh I
think our streaming software lost
connection there so I apologize to the
viewers there but then we are back uh
and better than ever what were we
talking about I I was having some
technical difficulties over here we were
talking about the league the legal end
of what we're going to see we're talking
about Roger Stone oh yeah so let me ask
you so let me ask you because I want to
get your take before I go to um the
Trump NDA kill or Jessica Denson here I
want to ask you about the Secret Service
into this because I know you said uh the
the testimony of Mike Pompeo um uh
secretary Chow Mitch McConnell's wife
after threatening them it seems like he
knows there's going to be something said
or gonna be something shown maybe and by
he I mean Grandpa poopy pants the Cheeto
dust mobster Donald Trump himself but
what do you expect to see from this
communication from the Secret Service I
mean it seems kind of funny that it was
lost then it's here then it's not only
got you know a gazillion lines of
communication what do you make of this
well this actually isn't isn't the text
that we're lost those those are just
gone they they did a good job of
deleting those and and they were
unrecoverable what this is is everything
before and after what you have to
understand is that like I said Tigers
don't change their stripes they were
having conversations before January 6
that are going to be very Illuminating
uh as to their positions on things and
and things that were going on
the events of the day aren't the only
isn't the only information to be had and
I I really think that a good
investigator is going to come through
these emails and these communications
and they're going to be able to
establish a pattern of behavior
with with the Secret Service and I I
don't think it's going to be flattering
for them at all to be quite honest with
you
I think you're right I don't think it's
going to be a great day for Roger Stone
or the Secret Service and especially
Donald Trump so Texas Paul thanks for
joining us and stick with us if you can
afterwards and then even during the
hearing if they have a break we're not
really sure exactly what they're going
to do Texas ball thank you very much I
appreciate it and everyone go follow
Texas Paul on YouTube he's got shows
that he's doing every single week so go
file Texas Paul over on YouTube all you
got to do is type in his handle or Texas
Paul morning coffee on Sunday morning
coffee with Texas ball you'll find it
you'll find Texas Ball's YouTube channel
there Texas ball appreciate it yeah
we'll talk to you very soon my friend
uh I want to introduce my next guest but
again I want to remind you
to make sure and go over to Midas Touch
patreon.com and support
independentmediapatreon.com Midas Touch
we could not do this without you
Independent Media is important and I
have to mention Jordy will be in the
chat with me saying why why why didn't
you show anybody the rovember shirt so
here is the remember shirts because
remember is coming up row row row your
votes to go over to store not minus
touch.com grab your row row row your
vote in November merch store that minus
Touchback I'm also again reminding you
if you'd like to support our podcast you
go to
store.thetonymichaels.com and you can
get the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty that is our
show's motto it's in the front of our
intro every single day we also have
some great colored hoodies over there
with an on and so we appreciate any
support you can give Independent Media
make sure while you're here on the Midas
touch Network that you're hitting the
Subscribe button sharing this link with
your friends your family they're
definitely going to want to see this
make sure you go over to our channel the
Tony Michaels podcast follow us there
again we could not do this Independent
Media thing without you
and I know our next guest knows that all
too well of how it is a fight fight
fight fight fight fight fight because
she is the Trump NDA killer my friend
Midas Mighty favorite Jessica dents and
Jessica how are you this morning I'm
doing great how are you Tony I'm doing
wonderful I'm doing wonderful so what do
you make of this hearing because there's
a lot of stuff
um going on today but it seems like
Donald Trump is going to be the main
character the main villain here that
they are going to really make sure the
American people understand what his role
in the January 6 Insurrection and the
coup attempt was
absolutely that's just what popoc was
talking about he was talking about my
favorite word men's Raya that the
Criminal Intent and knowledge of the
crime they this committee has has done
such an Exquisite job of highlighting
highlighting Donald Trump's intent his
knowledge of just starting off with the
knowledge of the fact that the election
was not in fact stolen today we are
going to see a lot of highlighting of
his knowledge that violence was planned
and his desire to stoke that violence to
encourage that violence
um as uh Cassidy Hutchinson we recall
testified
um he was warned of people wanting to
enter past through with um weapons with
without
um Donald Trump wanted people to be able
to enter these spaces without having to
go through magnetometers and he was fine
with that because he knew that they were
not there to hurt him they were on his
side they were not there to hurt him but
he was quite all right quite content
with them harming others so I think that
that load of 1.5 million documents
emails other Communications from Secret
Service today is going to go a long way
to corroborate Cassidy Hutchinson's
testimony that Donald Trump was aware of
the violence he was warned of it and he
was in favor of stoking that violence
um we were talking a lot about Roger
Stone now Roger Stone yes dirty
trickster somebody who absolutely cannot
stand to be out of the Limelight but as
always let us not forget the Nexus the
actual ringleader who is Donald J Trump
another thing that Cassidy Hutchinson
testified to was that Donald Trump asked
Mark Meadows or told Mark Meadows to ask
Roger Stone and Michael Flynn what was
going to happen on January 6th okay
these people were in constant
communication and they they were an
under standing that they were conspiring
and working together to make sure that
this execution of overthrowing the
overthrowing the will of the people
interfering with congress's
certification of the votes make sure
that that scheme was was playing out
Donald Trump is the ring leader
um so I am looking very very forward to
seeing those connections made I think
we're going to have some kind of
flooring exhibits and evidence from the
Secret Service to really point out what
this commander-in-chief this
commander-in-chief who was entrusted who
took an oath on the constitution on with
his hand on the Bible to uphold the
Constitution how he betrayed this
country how he was willing to literally
incite a civil war on the steps of our
Capital to install himself as dictator
I I couldn't agree more because that
there is a Washington Post article I
believe was yesterday the day before
they were actually uh talking about the
communication is going to show because
Donald Trump claims oh why I wasn't
watching TV and I was I was playing
around throwing ketchup on the wall all
afternoon I had no idea what was going
on in the capital but we're going to see
the communication that not only did
apparently not only did Donald Trump
want to go to the Capitol himself
um after getting off the stage at the
ellipse where we know now there was this
couple
um in the SUV as they were taking him
back to the White House
um secret service the communication
apparently is going to show that they
were very concerned that he was still
planning on making his way to the
Capitol and I don't know if it was some
sort of trump delusion which it probably
was where there's this constitutional
thing that doesn't really exist where he
was going to go and gavel in and declare
him self King and dictator I'm not
really sure what the plan was maybe we
will know more about that today but
apparently this communication is going
to show that they were really worried
that the president United States was
going to make his way to the Capitol
even as the the Insurrection the
violence and the rioting
um and and frankly the the coup attempt
now that we know what we're going to see
from Roger Stone and The Oath Keepers
they were trying to violently overthrow
our government was he going to appear
what do you make of that before before
we turn it over to someone else what do
you make of that Jessica yeah I think
Donald Trump he wanted to be there he
wanted to be there because he knew what
chaos that would that would cause if the
sitting president of the United States
was there on the steps of the capital
with these insurrectionists everything
would have just
collapsed and centered on the the
president of the United States okay his
his goal was to interfere with the
counting of the votes with the
certification of the election
his presence at the Capitol very likely
could have done that I mean who knows
what kind of Hell could have broken
loose if he was physically present at
the Capitol in that
in that Mayhem
um that was his goal to delay the
certification of the election and there
were a lot of um if if we go back I'm
I'm not recalling the exact examples
right now but there were so many
discussions about what their
possibilities these schemers what their
possibilities were to prolong and delay
and prevent the certification of Joe
Biden's win if they were able to just
push it past that day January 6th but as
we're as we're discussing all of this if
we can just step back step back for a
moment and realize Where We Are
think about all of the hearings that we
have had up until this point think about
all of the extraordinary Witnesses think
about Judge letting and sheamos and Ruby
Freeman think about Rusty Bowers think
about uh Jason Van Tate and hope the
former in bed of The Oath Keepers think
of all of these people many of them most
of them coming from the right of
American politics from the conservative
side
who have issued These Warnings to us
issued the warnings of the danger that
we are in and that danger still faces us
it faces us right at this moment or 26
days out from a midterm election where
we have the choice between two parties
only one of which has aligned itself
with democracy
the other one has aligned itself with
the man who these committees have proven
and shown in clear relief is guilty of
attempting to overthrow American
democracy think about that that is the
choice we have in 26 days all of these
Patriots have come forward as I said you
cannot call them partisan most of them
have come from the right issued These
Warnings of the Stark danger that we
face if we don't handle this now so as I
have always said if you've watched me
before you know this is my drum beat
Donald Trump must be held accountable
for our democracy to survive the other
people that must be held accountable are
Republican politicians who have failed
to distance themselves from him and
putting these people in power is a very
very dangerous proposition so as we're
sitting and watching today I hope
everybody feels that gravity that
urgency and that gratitude that we are
living in the moment to save our
democracy that it is still within our
grasp and let us not look back and wish
that we had done something now let's do
it in these next 26 days I couldn't have
said it better myself Jessica Denson I
know her as the Trump NDA killer thank
you so much for joining us are you going
to be able to stick around for maybe mid
coverage if we have a break and after I
I know you have sort of a hard out but
I'm hoping you can join us we stick
around if we can agree I I really
appreciate it Jessica thanks for joining
us uh we'll talk to you very soon follow
Jessica on Twitter
um Jessica give them give them your
handle there it's Jessica dunson07 thank
you very much Jessica we appreciate you
coming and visiting with us we'll talk
to you soon my friend hopefully we'll
get a break
um everyone I want to go to someone who
knows the politics of this
um but first first I want to bring in my
co-host and executive producer Gabe
Sanchez Gabe Sanchez how are you is your
mic working are we are it is now I don't
know what the technical difficulties
were there but we you know we're gonna
work through them these are live
broadcasts this is what live is baby do
it live do it live I think uh you know
if I it was is Trump and his coo crew
trying to shut this broadcast down for
people knowing what the truth might be
might be you know Jessica brought up a
good point that rovember is coming up
and again uh Jordy um he'll be in the
chat all over me if I don't show this
again November November November row row
row your vote go to
store.mindustouch.com
store.mindustouch.com and get your row
row row your vote
merch because you got to support
Independent Media okay what else are you
gonna do so go to patreon.com mydistouch
to support indepenia Independent Media
there support the Midas Dutch Network
also while you're here while you're here
on YouTube Follow the Midas touch
Network why wouldn't you it's just a
little click you just click the button
it's it's that it's that easy just click
it boom it's easy get it boom it's that
easy it's almost easier than the Staples
button and while you're here on YouTube
make your way over to our Channel Tony
Michaels podcast and follow us there we
do a show every single weekday Gabe
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central two full hours every single one
of those weekdays Monday through Friday
on YouTube so go follow us
and go follow our show over there I have
two guests waiting in the queue here
um a surprise guest maybe he'll give us
a legal analysis and I also have
political analysis here he's going to
give us the politics of the this as well
and I'm sure Ben myself will give this
politics but David Bender he has a shirt
on I'm seeing him in the Green Room
David Bender has a shirt on here it says
you know we got the row row row your
boat we even have this great shirt and
it's the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty at
store.the Tony michaels.com we got
hoodies and shirts but I'm telling you
what David Bender this shirt you got on
let me see this thing bye bye Donald bye
bye oh my God
after you buy the November shirt
and if you go to you know uh you can the
merch location that you can identify uh
Gabe and Tony uh for November for your
merch yeah this is something waiting for
when Merrick garland does what he's
gonna do oh I guess we're all gonna be
wearing this because that when that day
comes and my prediction is that day is
going to come somewhere around January
6th January 6th oh
if against anyone who's listening but if
Merrick Garland is paying attention the
new house is sworn in January 3rd what a
way to to steal their Thunder whoever it
is hopefully it's going to be not
stealing Thunder we're gonna thunder
back and win this thing and I I got to
pick up on what Chester could just say
it's 26 days to the election okay 26
days where everything is on the line
but the house is on the line in every
District in the country and there are
going to be a lot of surprises if our
folks turn out we saw it in the New York
District we've seen it you saw it in
Kansas this remember idea is very
important but now let me let me scare a
few people the inflation numbers came
out today they were not good
people are voting on the economy so if
you got two things that are motivating
people fear of the economy and fear of
their rights being taken away like Roe v
Wade was overturned I am wearing the
Human Rights Campaign like gay rights
will be taken away by this next Supreme
Court and more to come if those are the
choices and they are the choices on this
ballot
then what's the what's the Pivot Point
what puts the thumb on the scale
democracy
what we are doing right today with this
hearing if people vote on the basis of
protecting their democracy
and by the way there's a compelling
argument that Democrats can make about
uh the economy prescription drug
benefits which the Republicans are
already introducing a bill to remove
everything the Democrats did there there
are great economic arguments that we can
make in these closing 26 days but guys
I'm telling you and I'm telling everyone
in the sound of my voice we do not have
any time to waste leave nothing off the
field everybody has to be involved in
these next 26 days wherever you live
whatever you can do particularly if it's
a place like Arizona Mark Kelly Florida
Val demings Sherry Beasley in North
Carolina these are races and I'll tell
you something John fetterman in
Pennsylvania is not a lock this is going
to be a fight don't assume even though
the polls are showing good it's going to
be a fight and and he can win this thing
will win this thing if enough people
turn turn out and this is all done
campaigns my whole life guys you know
this yes all turn out yep well we we you
know we say on our shoe David that you
have to lean into democracy and do what
democracies do and just do democracy and
I know two gentlemen that agree with me
on that as well Ben and Brett my zealous
I'm not sure where jordy's at where
where did Jordan where where did he go
he's probably jordy's probably getting
his Beauty arrest so yeah
not a full you know there's a reason
Jordy is always glowing he's always
getting his beauty rest now I'm sure no
full house today we're working on
something else but great to see you
David great to see you Gabe and Tony
great job at the broadcast so far great
to see the Midas Mighty out here and I
think David's absolutely right take no
race for granted here don't believe the
polls take no race for Grant and
understand that we have really good
momentum but that momentum means nothing
if you're not putting in the work every
single day right now until election day
we have under four weeks until the
election is over done and so do you want
to wake up that day after election day
and think damn I could have done more
you know that that was always my regret
in the in the past election you know I I
was so fearful of waking up the day
after the election and going if only we
did X Y and Z and so don't let that
happen to you okay I want everybody to
make sure that you're in this every step
of the way also in regards to you know
issues like in inflation and whatnot the
fact is is that Republicans have no plan
for these things and in fact they are
cheering on any sort of bad news that
exists about the economy and they want
to see as much pain inflicted on
Americans as possible so I think it's
important when you're having
conversations with people that you make
people understand that and make people
know that Republicans literally have
zero plan for any of these things that
they complain about and you could even
see in the votes anytime there is a vote
to help one of these issues they vote it
down and then they try to make things
worse so if you do vote Republican over
these economic issues like inflation
which are Global issues happening all
across the world if you do vote for
republicans in that you will not get a
fix to inflation or gas prices I mean
that's you you're not going to get it
what you will get though is
authoritarianism you will get banned
books you will get your abortion right
Stripped Away on a national level you
will get contraception Stripped Away and
so I think it's important that you
understand that your literal freedoms
what our democracy is built upon are at
stake in this election and that's why
it's so important that you vote for
Democrats and all the great things that
they've done and also against
Republicans and all the horrible things
that they have done and the Embrace of
just really horrific horrible conspiracy
theories I mean we saw it yesterday with
Alex Jones how all these people rush to
his defense and all these people who
platformed Alex Jones one of the most
despicable people on the planet who
harassed the victims of a school
shooting and their families tortured
them made them move drove one to Suicide
I mean these are horrible people and
these are the people who the Republican
Party are uplifting and are are viewing
as their Heroes and so we cannot let
those people get into power we need
adults in the room and that's where all
you come into play and I want to make
sure also as we get within 15 minutes of
these January 6 committee hearings make
sure that as many people that you know
are watching the January 6 committee
hearings because these are incredibly
revealing these are obviously not in
prime time today are there a lot of
people working but a lot of people watch
YouTube and and watch the stuff while
they're working so take a second go
share this link with a friend go share
this link with 10 friends with your
family members make sure they're tuned
in because their democracy literally
depends on it
I couldn't agree with you more and Ben
um I know you're probably going to give
us the political side but
your mind is focused a lot on legal
issues it seems like these days because
there's so many of them surrounding
Donald Trump
um they never they never stop the legal
issues around Donald Trump what is your
take on the hearing today and what is
what is important to look for from the
hearing and not only that because me and
popeck talked in the beginning about
this this intersection of this trial
with The Oath Keepers and this hearing
today we know it was postponed because
of the hurricane but now today it's in
this cross-section of this weird
Twilight Zone where we have a criminal
trial on one side of the street and we
have this political select hearing on
the other side of the street what do you
make of that
not just a criminal trial of The Oath
Keepers on the other side of the street
it's breaking news that Mark short the
former Chief of Staff of Vice President
Pence and cash Patel the Trump advisor
and former National Security aide who
was intimately involved in trying to
overthrow our democracy that these two
Trump Administration officials were seen
today leaving the Washington D.C federal
courthouse in addition to what was
taking place by The Oath Keepers all the
things that Brett mentioned though on
the political side all of the
implications coming up with this
election are intertwined with January 6
and are intertwined with the legal
because when we're talking about
overthrowing our democracy we're talking
about fundamentally one of the things
the radical Maga extremists want to do
is overthrow our judicial system and
fortunately in 2020 our Judicial System
held even where it came to Trump
appointed judges but the stress test
only barely held and we're seeing what's
happening though where you have very
inexperienced and corrupt judges like
judge Eileen Cannon down in the southern
district of Florida imagine if one of
these election cases were assigned to
judge Eileen Cannon one of those you
know 74 cases or so that Trump summarily
lost for merits-based arguments and the
fact that literally kind of Fraud and
phony people who weren't supposed to
bring the case were the ones bringing
those cases without declarations without
affidavits think about what judge Eileen
Cannon did in this case she granted an
injunction stopping the Department of
Justice from pursuing their own criminal
investigation using their own records
without requiring Donald Trump to even
submit an affidavit in fact when the
special Master uh judge Raymond Deary
said Donald Trump should submit an
affidavit you appointed me to be part of
this process this judge Eileen Cannon
swoops in and goes no no you don't need
to submit any affidavits only the
government needs to submit an affidavit
I'm going to protect you Donald Trump
you know so we're really dealing with
the protection of our institutions here
and in the January 6th committee which
is bipartisan and you have Liz Cheney
and Adam kinzinger in addition to the
other Democrats the fact that all
Witnesses
really have been 98 Republican Witnesses
um shows you though that this is an
Institutional and importance of our
institutions fighting back against
fascism and that's really how how I view
the January 6 through that prism here
will our institutions hold over
lawlessness recklessness stupidity
idiocracy dangerousness fascism
thing to add I I think someone has tried
to join us here
um
did you guys tell everyone I was getting
my beauty rest so for are so for
everyone to watch right now the brothers
treat me as like their glorified
assistant we just did an interview and I
had to like get all the files organize
everything and the next thing I know
they're already on the stream this is
ridiculous is Jordy actually over there
working or is this this all I'll just
say we all share the same calendar we
all know what time what is so you know I
just I just wanna but before our
audience Jordy acted like that was a lot
of work so what Jordy said he had to do
is literally take the file and then put
the file in another file it literally
takes two seconds and we all do it great
I'm sure a lot of people right now who
are at work with really tough tasks
ahead of them are really uh
I hope you take this the right way but
the Beautyrest worked oh thank you David
oh man take it exactly as the compliment
It's Made I gotta pick up on something
your brother said you know it is
absolutely true that the institutions
are on the line here and they're being
stress tested with everything that we're
seeing we've got the Oath Keepers trial
going on one of the things that is
stunning we're learning how many members
of law enforcement are members of Oath
Keepers or problems I think the number
is something like 350 active members of
law enforcement are also still Oath
Keepers so we are fighting not only to
preserve the institutions but we've got
to now do stress tests within the
institutions and that's sort of what
this committee is doing this committee
is showing us how government can work
it's the last civics lesson we're ever
going to get as well done as this
committee has done it it shows the way
government works when people are really
trying to solve problems not just make
political points and that's what's so
important about what we're going to see
today guys I think and and for everyone
listening I couldn't agree more uh
tell your friends tune into the modest
touch Network here on YouTube watch
these hearings coming up in eight
minutes because this is the summation
this is the closing argument to the
American people
there are there will be witness
testimony but not live Witnesses we're
going to see some of these people from
videotape but this is the committee
talking directly to you to say here's
what we've learned and here's what we
have to do
I'd also like to speak about
institutions in the sense of how
institutions can work to protect
themselves at all costs and that's
really what we're seeing right now with
the Republican party and and we've seen
that in in reporting recently with
leaked audio between uh officer Fanon
who was there in the capital of that day
and the conversations he had with Kevin
McCarthy and how Kevin McCarthy refused
to speak out
um about what the truth about what
happened that day and we've seen it
recently in recent weeks with Herschel
Walker who was exposed as an absolute
fraud was exposed as an abuser who
forced his family to move six times in
six months I believe it was because they
were afraid of his violence
um lied about uh paying for abortions
which on its own isn't a bad thing but
when you're trying to strip that right
away from millions of Americans it
becomes a problem for me
um and just notice how also yesterday we
saw so many of these right-wing voices
who are very trusted stream voices on
the right go out of their way to defend
Alex Jones and try to Gaslight you and
try to say this is you know an attack on
free speech and he just said some mean
words I just want you to understand how
this Republican party is built to
protect each other and to also Crush
dissent and it cannot be more important
going into these midterms that we
understand how they are so against the
truth they are they will fight the truth
at all costs and they will defend their
own and how dangerous that is in order
for a democracy to actually function
they they can't be trusted telling the
truth about anything and so it's very
important that they're not in charge of
our government especially with so many
important issues going on both here and
around the world we just can't do that
you know Brett I I was in an event last
night talking about courage and talking
about the ability to to move forward
despite the odds I met Gabby Giffords
last night incredible this is a genuine
American Hero
and it it struck me uh when I woke up
this morning and saw the Parkland
verdict Could Happen uh Gabby Giffords
survived she was one percent chance of
survival and she spoke last night and
she talked about how no matter what
happens
and we've seen some tough times as a
country but no one has seen what Gabby
Giffords has seen and what her family
has seen
um and there's a documentary about it
which Gabby Giffords won't back down I
encourage everyone to watch I hope he
gets nominated for an oscar but let me
tell you something the point that Gabby
Giffords made and she wasn't even
supposed to be able to speak again
was that we have to stay in this fight
no matter how tough it is and if you
think of Gabby Giffords for the next 26
days and her husband Mark Kelly and all
the other candidates on the line and
everybody that you talked about
righteous now that Herschel Walker
people like that these we're talking
about not a choice between uh right and
left we're talking about choice between
right and wrong exactly and and wrong
cannot win we have the muscle if we
exercise it there are more of us than
there are of them that's why you know
remember Gabby Giffords for the next 26
days she did it we can too hey her story
is just so inspiring at David and that's
why I loved hearing this week at the
debate between Tim Ryan and JD Vance
when he used the phrase the exhausted
majority I think that's sums to set
things up so much and and especially in
light of what we've seen over these
recent weeks but
and like we saw like I've been speaking
about with Alex Jones and I loved what
you just said about it's not right first
left it's right first wrong when you
look at the Alex Jones situation let's
let's view that as a microcosm of
everything wrong with the Republican
party that's not a right first left
issue there's nothing right first that's
not it's not a democratic belief to not
want people to harass families of
victims of school shootings and and make
them move and drive some to sue us
that's not a democratic belief that's
not on the left I mean I was never even
a political person before we started
Midas Touch but I looked at people
coming out like that and trying to put
that in a left right Paradigm and I said
[ __ ] this is an American belief this
is just a not even an American belief
this is a being a human this is basic
humanity and so don't let them put basic
Humanity into this Left Right Paradigm
because it's BS it's BS there is right
the wrong as David Bender said and it's
important that we all remember that and
it's important that though we may be
exhausted and boy am I exhausted and I
think think we all are exhausted
watching this every single day it's
important that we are not asleep it's
important that we are activated and that
we are energized and you mentioned you
mentioned something I've got to pick up
on which was probably the best moment
we're going to have to show what
Democrats can do to win this it's that
JD Vance Tim Ryan debate when Tim Ryan
looked him in the eye and said you're
kissing Donald Trump's ass so good just
to get his support and you will do
anything we need ass kickers not ass
kissers if every Democrat running
against every Trump Republican does the
same thing stares them down and ties
them directly to Donald Trump
they will go down in flames remember
what happened this is why we have those
two Georgia seats because Trump weighed
in Trump is is dead weight to these
candidates so tie them if any Democrats
are listening tie them to Trump so Jordy
give us your best pitch for rovember as
I pull up the graphic here because I
don't even know I was wearing the shirt
right now
well I'll get back to it as the graphics
done go to
store.mindustouch.com for your real real
your vote in rovember shirt
um show us what you got there but give
us your best bench uh best [ __ ] um that
you've got for remember show us the
church show us the shirt yeah the shirt
right you got the shirt right here yeah
no it's look it's a great shirt but the
message is more important than the t but
definitely go pick one up we know what's
on the line This November if all you
watching this stream you know what's on
the line This November if you have a
sibling a a daughter a sister a cousin
you know what's at stake you know it's
more than just a slogan it's really it's
a movement and you all have to use
whatever voice that you have you know in
your inner circles with your family with
your co-workers to speak up and speak
out because remember is on the line This
November so please get out there and
vote because the stakes have never been
higher and I know that sounds cliche but
it's deadly serious so please please get
out there and vote and on a much lighter
note it looks like I kicked Ben off The
Stream which is amazing
um and please
yeah and please take a second right now
take this link and share it on your
Facebook on your Twitter wherever
whatever social media and let people
know that the stream is happening right
now you know every there's a whole bunch
of people joining right now which is
amazing the stream continues to grow a
lot of folks don't even know the January
6th hearing is happening today which
just blows my mind I mean it's
unfortunate that it's not a prime time
hearing so please do whatever you can
and with your role in your social media
reach to take this Lincoln and share
with your friends and family and let
them know this thing is going live right
now
well and we're still waiting um I'm
watching the feed as we speak
um and the feed that we have is just not
in the room yet on this tile right here
so we're so we're still waiting uh for
the for for the committee to to enter in
as we wait though as we wait Gabe
Sanchez I want to get your take because
I know we have talked a lot about Roger
Stone on our show now we refer to him as
stodger Roan right we don't want to you
know allegedly there's this guy named
stodgerone that may or may not have
communication and we've we've
we viewed just a bit just tiny bits of
this documentary what do you make of
stodgerone otherwise known as Roger
Stone yes what happened to him today and
how good of a day our battle day he'll
have I mean just just for the fact that
we're able to view or get uh insight
into the Danish film The a storm
foretold that is about Roger Stone I
mean I I will say this
Mega Republicans or anyone on the on the
right has this incredible ability to
project or or put their crime on display
we see it across the board whether it's
hey I'm openly committing this fraud and
make sure to take a photo everyone we
saw it in the Willard Hotel in the war
room we see him openly discussing this
on the phone showing the signal chats
that he's got with different people
we see
we see conversations that are being
recorded in this film so again it is
it's mind-blowing how much of these
people are willing to show the crime
that's being committed
for whether it's this inability to see
themselves as criminals or they feel
like they're never going to get caught
but I feel like there's going to be a
lot of revealing things that come up
whether it's the messages that are going
to be shown from the Secret Service I
know that you know popoc mentioned
there's over a million I know none of
those million that were just recovered
are including the text messages it's
also of course very suspicious that it's
only the fifth and the sixth that were
for a phone upgrade doesn't make much
sense uh but again for Roger Stone this
guy is very much the proxy between the
White House
and The Oath Keepers or the Secret
Service so I feel like he is the direct
through line between either side that
says hey we want to do XYZ and
committing this coup and he's the
channel that gets through to say Hey Big
Man is this okay to do and then
obviously
Donald Trump the big man uh as many
people know him as uh or the boss or
whatever they called him and that
mafia-like talk that we're probably
going to see clips of
is going to show that he's he's
definitely guilty of these crimes he's
connected it looks like they've entered
the room so I'm gonna go to the the feed
here
um fellas joining us in Authority we're
going to go to the hearing the chair
analysis
to release the deposition material
presented during today's hearing
good afternoon
and may God bless the United States of
America
four months ago
this committee started to present our
findings to you the American people
from the beginning we understood that
some people watching those proceedings
would wrongly assume that the
committee's investigation was a partisan
exercise
that's why I asked those who were
skeptical of our work to Simply to
listen
to listen to the evidence to hear the
testimony with an open mind
and to let the facts speak for
themselves before reaching any judgment
over the course of these hearings the
evidence has proven that there were
multi-part plan led by former president
Donald Trump to overturn the 2020
election
Donald Trump lost his bid for
re-election as shown from the testimony
of some of the president's closest
allies and advisers Donald Trump knew he
lost despite this knowledge Donald Trump
went to court the contest the 2020
election and he lost in court
the Electoral College met and declared
Joe Biden the winner yet Donald Trump
continued to pull out all the stops in
his attempt to stay in power
but Donald Trump proceeded to do after
the 2020 election is something no
president has done before in our country
in a staggering betrayal of his oath
Donald Trump attempted a plan that led
to an attack on a pillar of our
democracy is still hard to believe
but the facts and testimony are clear
consistent and Undisputed how do we know
this
how have we been able to present such a
clear picture of what took place
because of the testimony we've heard and
that we've now presented to you through
these proceedings because of the
documentary evidence we've gathered and
also made available directly to you the
American people
when you look back at what has come out
through this committee's work the most
striking fact is that all this evidence
come almost entirely from Republicans
the evidence that has emerged did not
come from Democrats or opponents of
Donald Trump
instead look at who's ridden and
testified and produced evidence
who has that been
aides who've worked loyally for Donald
Trump for years
Republican state officials and
legislators Republican electors the
chairwoman or the Republican National
Committee
political professionals who worked at
the highest levels of the Trump campaign
Trump appointees who served in the most
senior positions in the Justice
Department
president Trump's staff and closest
advisors in the White House
members of the president Trump's family
his own White House Council
I've served in Congress a long time
I can tell you it's tough for any
Congressional investigation to obtain
evidence like what we've received least
of all such a detailed view into a
president's Inner Circle
and I want to be clear
not all these Witnesses were thrilled to
talk to us some up put up quite a fight
but ultimately the vast majority
cooperated with our investigation
and what we've shown you over the last
four months has been centered on the
evidence evidence that has come
overwhelmingly from Republican Witnesses
so I say to you again as I did in June
this investigation is not about politics
it's not about party
it's about the facts plain and simple
and it's about making sure our
government functions under the rule of
law as our constitution demands today as
in previous proceedings my colleagues
and I will present new evidence
that includes new testimony from
additional Republicans who served in the
Trump Administration
never best foreseen footage of
congressional leaders on January 6
working to coordinate the response to
the violence and ensure the people's
business went forward
new materials produced to the committee
by the Secret Service details about the
ongoing threat to American democracy
today's proceeding will also be grounded
in the facts but it won't look exactly
like all our other hearings
we'll also take a step back and look at
the evidence in a broader context
providing a summary of key facts we've
uncovered
facts relevant to former president
Trump's state of mind about his
motivation and about his intent
what did President Trump know
what was he told
what was his personal and substantial
role in a multi-part plan to overturn
the election
for those of you who've watched our
prior hearings some of this evidence
will look familiar
for those of you tuning in for the first
time we'll summarize some of the most
important facts and we urge you to go
online and watch our Hearing in full
there's one more difference about today
pursuant to the notice circulated prior
to today's proceedings we are convened
today not as a hearing but as a formal
committed business meeting so that in
addition to presenting evidence we can
potentially hold a committed vote on
further investigative action based upon
that evidence before we get to that
evidence I'd recognize our distinguished
Vice chair Ms Cheney of Wyoming for any
opening statement she care to offer
thank you very much Mr chairman much has
happened since our last public hearing
on July 21st as the chairman mentioned
we've received new and voluminous
documentation from the Secret Service
which we continue to analyze
we've received new witness testimony
including about efforts to obstruct our
investigation and conceal key facts
and according to public reporting the
Department of Justice has been very
active in pursuing many of the issues
identified in our prior hearings
our committee May ultimately decide to
make a series of Criminal referrals to
the Department of Justice but we
recognize that our role is not to make
decisions regarding prosecution
the preamble to our constitution recites
among its purposes to quote establish
justice
in our nation's Judiciary and our U.S
Department of Justice have that
responsibility
a key element of this committee's
responsibility is to propose reforms to
prevent January 6th from ever happening
again
we've already proposed and the house has
now passed a bill to amend the Electoral
count act to help ensure that no other
future plots to overturn an election can
succeed
and we will make further specific
recommendations in our final report
based in part on the evidence you will
hear today
our hearings last summer began with an
outline of President Trump's multi-part
plan to overturn the 2020 presidential
election
we then proceeded to demonstrate each of
these elements in detail with more than
20 hours of evidence today we will see
new evidence but as the chairman said we
will also synthesize evidence you've
seen before
the vast weight of evidence presented so
far has shown us that the central cause
of January 6th was one man Donald Trump
whom many others followed
none of this would have happened without
him he was personally and substantially
involved in all of it
exactly how did one man cause all of
this
today we will focus on President Trump's
State of Mind his intent his motivations
and how he spurred others to do his
bidding and how Another January 6th
could happen again if we do not take
necessary action to prevent it
as you view our evidence today I would
suggest a focus on the following points
first
as you will see President Trump had a
premeditated plan to declare that the
election was fraudulent and stolen
before election day before he knew the
election results
he made his stolen election claims on
Election night against the advice of his
campaign without any evidence in hand
then over the next two months he sought
to find those who would help him invent
and spread lies about the widespread
fraud
many of those who stepped forward to
help including Rudy Giuliani knew
they never had real evidence sufficient
to change the election results and on
the evening of January 5th they admitted
they were still trying to find that
Phantom evidence
of course as a result of making
intentionally false claims of election
fraud Mr giuliani's license to practice
law has now been suspended
second please recognize that President
Donald Trump was in a unique position
better informed about the absence of
widespread election fraud than almost
any other American
president Trump's own campaign experts
told him that there was no evidence to
support his claims his own justice
department appointees investigated the
election fraud claims and told him Point
Blank they were false
in mid-December 2020 president Trump's
senior advisors told him the time had
come to concede the election
Donald Trump knew the courts had ruled
against him
he had all of this information but still
he made the conscious choice to claim
fraudulently that the election was
stolen to pressure State officials to
change election results to manufacture
fake electoral slates to attempts to
corrupt our department of justice
to summon tens of thousands of
supporters to Washington
knowing that they were angry knowing
that some of them were armed he sent
them to the Capitol
then as the riot was underway he incited
his supporters to further Violence by
publicly condemning his vice president
and then he refused for hours to disband
his rioting supporters and instruct them
to leave the capitol even when he was
begged repeatedly to do so
none of this is normal or acceptable or
lawful in our Republic
third please consider today who had a
hand in defeating president Trump's
efforts to overturn the election
vice president Pence Bill Barr Jeff
Rosen and others at the Department of
Justice
State Republican officials White House
staff who blocked proposals to mobilize
the military to seize voting machines
and run new elections
our Capitol Police aided by the
Metropolitan Police other federal law
enforcement and our National Guard who
arrived later in the afternoon all of
these people had a hand in stopping
Donald Trump
this leads us to a key question
why would Americans assume that our
Constitution and our institutions in our
Republic are invulnerable to another
attack
why would we assume that those
institutions will not falter next time a
key lesson of this investigation is this
our institutions only hold when men and
women of good faith make them hold
regardless of the political cost
we have no guarantee that these men and
women will be in place next time
any future president inclined to attempt
what Donald Trump did in 2020 has now
learned not to install people who could
stand in the way
and also please consider this
the rulings of our courts are respected
and obeyed because we as Citizens pledge
to accept and honor them
most importantly our president who has a
constitutional obligation to Faithfully
execute the laws swears to accept them
what happens when the president
disregards the Court's rulings as
illegitimate when he disregards the rule
of law
that my fellow citizens breaks our
Republic
finally as you view the evidence today
also consider this
president Trump knew
from unassailable sources that his
election fraud claims were false
he admitted he had lost the election he
took actions consistent with that belief
claims that President Trump actually
thought the election was stolen
are not supported by a fact and are not
a defense there is no defense that
Donald Trump was duped or irrational
no president can defy the rule of law
and act this way in a constitutional
republic period
Mr chairman our nation's federal judges
are sworn to do impartial Justice to
preserve our Constitution and preserve
our Union
dozens of these judges have been
addressing January 6 cases and many have
given us plain unmistakable warnings
about the direction of our Republic
let me read from one judge's statement
given at a recent sentencing hearing
quote
high-ranking members of Congress and
State officials who know perfectly well
the claim of fraud was and is untrue
and that the election was legitimate are
so afraid of losing their power they
won't say so
it has to be crystal clear that it is
not patriotism it is not standing up for
America to stand up for one man who
knows full well that he lost instead of
the Constitution he was trying to
subvert
Mr chairman the violence and lawlessness
of January 6th was unjustifiable
but our nation cannot only punish the
foot soldiers who stormed our capital
those who plan to overturn our election
and brought us to the point of violence
must also be accountable
with every effort to excuse or Justify
the conduct of the former president we'd
chip away at the foundation of our
Republic
indefensible conduct is defended in
excusable conduct is excused without
accountability It all becomes normal and
it will recur
so as we watch the evidence today
please consider where our nation is in
its history
consider whether we can survive for
another 246 years
most people in most places on Earth have
not been free
America is an exception
and America continues only because we
bind ourselves to our Founders
principles to our constitution
we recognize that some principles must
be Beyond politics in Violet and more
important than any single American who
has ever lived thank you Mr chairman I
yield back
without objections the chair recognizes
the gentlewoman from California is
Lofgren for an opening statement
uh thank you Mr chairman uh very uh
shortly after the election oh uh we
begin this meeting by returning to
election night November 3rd 2020. as the
chairman noted we've previously
presented testimony about how the
election results were expected to come
in that night in certain States ballots
cast by mail before election day would
be counted only after the polls closed
that evening that meant that election
results would not be known for some time
although president Trump's campaign
manager Bill stapian house Republican
leader Kevin McCarthy and Jared Kushner
had advised Donald Trump to encourage
mail and voting by Republicans president
Trump did not do so
yeah I just remember generally you know
you had people arguing that we had a
very very robust get out the vote effort
and that you know mail-in ballots could
be a good thing uh for us if we looked
at it correctly there was one meeting
that was had
in particular
I invited Kevin McCarthy to
join the meeting
of like mind on on the issue
with me
um in which we
made our case
for for why
we believed male invaliding mail-in
voting um
not to be a bad thing for his campaign
um
but um you know the president's mind was
was made up
so it was expected before the election
that the initial counts in some states
in other words those votes cast on
Election Day would be more heavily
Republican and this would create the
false perception of a lead for president
Trump a so-called red Mirage but as the
results of the absentee ballots that
were later counted uh there could be
Trends towards Vice President Biden as
those mail-in ballots were counted now
on Election night Donald Trump's
advisors specifically told him he didn't
have a factual basis to declare a
victory that he should wait for the
remaining ballots to be counted here is
campaign manager bill stepian
it was far too early to be making any
calls like that
ballots
ballots were still being counted ballots
were still going to be accounted for
days
um and it was far too early to be making
any Proclamation like that I believe
my recommendation was to
say that
oats were still being counted
too early to to to tell too early to
call the race
but president Trump did declare victory
in the late hours of election night not
only did he declare Victory he also
called for the ongoing count of votes to
just stop
ping the count would have violated both
federal and state laws and also
disenfranchised millions of Voters who
lawfully cast their vote
he called for that action anyway here's
what he said
this is a fraud on the American public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election frankly we did win this
election
[Applause]
we want all
voting to stop
we now know more about President Trump's
intention for election night the
evidence shows that his false victory
speech was planned well in advance
before any votes had been counted it was
a premeditated plan by the president to
declare Victory no matter what the
actual result was he made a plan to stay
in office before election day
now the vice president staff was
concerned with what Donald Trump might
do on Election night they took steps to
ensure that Mr Pence would not Echo a
false Victory announcement from
president Trump
here's what the vice president's Council
Greg Jacob told us about his
preparations with the vice president's
Chief of Staff Mark short
Mark had indicated to me that uh
there was
a possibility that there would be
a declaration of victory
um within the White House that some
might push forward uh and this is prior
to their election results being known
and that he was trying to figure out a
way of
um
avoiding the vice president sort of
being thrust into a position of
uh
uh
needing to opine on that when he might
not have sufficient information to do so
now following this conversation Mr Jacob
drafted a memo to Mr short which the
Celeb committee got from the National
Archives
the memo was sent on November 3rd
election day
uh and advised it is essential that the
vice president not be perceived by the
public as having decided questions
concerning disputed electoral Vic votes
prior to the full development of all
relevant facts a few days before the
election Mr Trump also consulted with
one of his outside advisors
inside activist Tom fitton about the
strategy for election night the select
committee got this pre-prepared
statement from the National Archives
as you can see the draft statement which
was set on October 31st declares we had
an election today and I won
and the fit and memo specifically
indicates a plan that only the votes
counted by the election day deadline and
there is no election day deadline would
matter
everyone knew that ballot counting would
lawfully continue past election day
claiming that the counting on Election
night must stop before millions of votes
were counted was as we now know a key
part of President Trump's premeditated
plan
on Election Day just after 5 PM Mr
fitton indicated he'd spoken with the
president about the statement
sending along again just talk to him
about the draft below again this plan to
keep
to declare victory was in place before
any of the results had been determined
in the course of our investigation we
also interviewed rad parscale president
Trump's former campaign manager he told
us he understood that President Trump
planned as early as July that he would
say he won the election even if he lost
and just a few days before the election
Steve Bannon a former Trump chief White
House strategist and outside adviser to
president Trump spoke to a group of his
associates from China
and said this
and what Trump's going to do is just
declare Victory right he's going to
declare victory
but that doesn't mean he's the winner
he's just going to save the winner the
Democrats more of our people vote
early that count there's voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and Trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy he's
going to turn something winner so when
you wake up Wednesday morning
it's going to be a Firestone
also if Trump is if Trump is losing
by 10 or 11 o'clock at night it's going
to be even crazier
no because he's going to sit right there
and said they stole it yeah I'm
directing the Attorney General to shut
down all ballot places in all 50 states
it's gonna be no he's not going out easy
Trump if Biden's winning Trump is going
to do some crazy [ __ ]
as you know Mr Bannon refused to testify
in our investigation he's been convicted
of criminal contempt of congress and
he's awaiting sentencing
but the evidence indicates that Mr
Bannon had Advanced knowledge of Mr
Trump's intent to clear Victory falsely
on Election night but also that Mr
Bannon knew about Mr Trump's planning
for January 6th here's what Bannon said
on January 5th
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow it's all converging and now
we're on as they say the point of attack
right the point of attack tomorrow
I'll tell you this
it's not going to happen like you think
it's going to happen okay it's going to
be quite extraordinarily different and
all I can say is strap in you have made
this happen and tomorrow it's game day
so strap in let's get ready
another close associate of Donald Trump
apparently knew of Mr Trump's intentions
as well
now Roger Stone is a political operative
with a reputation for dirty tricks in
November 2019 he was convicted of lying
to Congress and other crimes and
sentenced to more than three years in
prison he's also a long time advisor to
president Trump and was in communication
with President Trump throughout 2020. Mr
Trump pardoned Roger stone on December
23rd 2020. now recently the select
committee got footage of Mr Stone before
and after the election from Danish
filmmaker Christopher gilbranson
pursuant to a subpoena right before the
election here's Roger Stone talking
about what president Trump would do
after the election
let's just hope we're celebrating I
suspect it'll be I really do suspect
that it would still be up in the air
when that happens the key thing to do is
to claim victory possession is nine
tenths of law no we won [ __ ] you sorry
over you're wrong [ __ ] you ABC I said
[ __ ] the Lord and let's get right to the
violence
foreign
the select committee called Mr Stone as
a witness but he invoked his Fifth
Amendment right against
self-incrimination
uh on the advice for Council I
respectfully uh declined to answer your
question on the basis of the Fifth
Amendment and Mr Stone did you have any
role in planning for the violence on
January 6th once again I will assert my
Fifth Amendment right to decline to
answer your question
although we don't yet have all the
relevant records of Roger Stone's
Communications even Stone's own social
media posts acknowledged that he spoke
with Donald Trump on December 27th as
preparations for January 6th were
underway
in this post you can see how Roger Stone
talked about his conversations with
President Trump he wrote I also told the
president exactly how he can appoint a
special counsel with full subpoena power
to ensure those who are attempting to
steal the 2020 election through voter
fraud are charged and convicted and to
ensure Donald Trump continues as our
president
as we know by now the idea for a special
counsel was not just an idle suggestion
it was something president Trump had
actually tried to do earlier that month
we know that Roger Stone was at the
Willard Hotel on January 5th and 6th and
we know from other witness testimony
that President Trump asked his Chief of
Staff Mark Meadows to speak with Roger
Stone and general Michael Flynn that
night
in addition to his connection to
president Trump Roger Stone maintained
extensive direct connections to two
groups responsible for violently
attacking the capital The Oath Keepers
and the proud boys
individuals from both of these
organizations have been charged with a
crime of seditious conspiracy now what
is seditious conspiracy it is a
conspiracy to use violent Force against
the United States to oppose the lawful
authority of the United States
multiple Associates of Roger Stone from
both The Oath Keepers and the proud boys
have been charged with this crime
Close Associates of Roger Stone
including Joshua James have pled guilty
to this crime we know that at least
seven Oath Keepers who have been
criminally charged provided personal
security for Roger Stone or were seen
with him on January 6 or in the weeks
leading up to January 6th for example
Joshua James the leader of the Alabama
Oath Keepers provided security for Roger
Stone and was with him on January 5th
this is uh the picture of the two uh
together on January 5th
James entered the capital on January 6th
he assaulted a police officer earlier
this year he pled guilty to seditious
conspiracy and respect and obstruction
of Congress
another example is the married couple
Kelly and Connie Meigs a Kelly Meigs was
the leader of the Florida chapter of The
Oath Keepers both he and his wife
provided security for Roger Stone and
both are charged with leading a
military-style stack attack of Oath
Keepers attacking the capital on January
6.
perhaps even more disturbing is Roger
Stone's close association with Enrique
tario
the national chairman of The Proud boys
Roger Stone's connection with Enrique
atario and the proud boys is well
documented
by video evidence with phone records the
select committee has obtained
um tario along with other proud boys has
been charged with multiple crimes
concerning the attack on January 6
including seditious conspiracy
during the attack tario sent a message
to other proud boys claiming we did that
he also visited the White House on
December 12th
later that day
he posted a disturbing video claiming
credit for the attack this video posted
on January 6th was apparently created
prior to the attack
this big lie president Trump's effort to
convince Americans that he had won the
2020 election
began before the election results even
came in it was intentional it was
premeditated it was not based on
election results or any evidence of
actual fraud affecting the results or
any actual problems with voting machines
it was a plan concocted in advance to
convince his supporters that he won
and the people who seemingly knew about
that plan in advance would ultimately
play a significant role in the events of
January 6. Mr chairman I yield back
the young woman heals back the chair
recognizes the gentleman from Illinois
Mr kinsinger for an opening statement
thank you Mr chairman very shortly after
the election
the Trump campaign recognized that they
had likely lost the election and they
informed Donald Trump of that fact
even before the networks called the race
for President Biden on November 7th his
chances of pulling out a victory were
virtually non-existent and president
Trump knew it
do you know if anybody ever told the
president that he had lost and that
there wasn't a chance of him winning
the I know that the president when the
networks called it of course he was
informed about the the network decision
um that afternoon at some point myself
and a handful of other folks went over
and sat down with the president
and
um communicated
uh that the the odds of us prevailing in
legal challenges uh were very small you
know after the election as of November
7th in your judgment what were the
chances of President Trump winning the
election after that point yes none
at times president Trump acknowledged
the reality of his loss
although he publicly claimed that he had
won the election privately he admitted
that Joe Biden would take over as
president here's a few examples of that
so we're in the old world there's a
discussion going on
and the President says
I think it could have been Pompeo but he
says words to the effect of
yeah we lost we needed we need to let
that issue go to the next guy being
president
I remember maybe a week after the
election was called I popped into the
oval just to like give the president the
headlines and see how he was doing and
he was looking at the TV and he said can
you believe I lost to this happen guy
Mark raised it with me on the 18th and
so following that conversation where the
motor came right driving back to the
White House
and I said like does the president
really think that he lost
and he said you know a lot of times
he'll tell me that he lost but he wants
to keep fighting it and he thinks that
there might be enough to overturn the
election but you know he he pretty much
has acknowledged that he that he's lost
knowing that he had lost and that he had
only weeks left in office president
Trump rushed to complete his unfinished
business
one key example is this
president Trump issued an order for
large-scale U.S troop withdrawals
he disregarded concerns about the
consequences for fragile governments on
the front lines of the fight against
Isis and Al Qaeda terrorists
knowing he was leaving office he acted
immediately and signed this order on
November 11th which would have required
the immediate withdrawal of troops from
Somalia and Afghanistan all to be
complete before the Biden inauguration
on January 20th
as you watch these clips recall that
General Keith Kellogg was the National
Security adviser to the vice president
and had served as Chief of Staff to the
National Security Council for president
Trump and general milley was the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff at
the Pentagon
are you familiar with a memo that the
president reportedly signed up November
11 2020
ordering that troops to be withdrawn
from Afghanistan and Somalia yes
so I think you might have seen some
things where
um there's a memo or something
from Johnny mcatee
to Douglas McGregor
it says here's your task to get U.S
forces out of uh out of uh Somalia get
your sources out of Afghanistan when you
first interviewed and met Colonel
Douglas McGregor is it fair to say you
discussed this
decision of withdrawing from Somalia in
Afghanistan correct
yeah I'm sure that was part of it yeah
and that was
the position that he was taking over
there was senior advisor to the
secretary of defense is that correct yes
so on that same day just so I'm clear he
responded back to you that they meaning
DOD leadership was not going to
do take any of those steps without an
order without a directive yeah I
explained in in language that should be
in the order while I was in the meeting
with mcentee and this was my answer to
him and said if you want this to happen
or if president wants this to happen
he's got to write an order
so you never wrote this down in any
capacity well I sketched on a piece of
paper for him some key statements
uh you know the president directs you
know this is
the
what's the right word boilerplate
language who was in his office drafted
the order
it was uh myself and one of my
assistants
mcentee Dooley types it up
brings it in to the president
signs it and boom it's over faxed over
or emailed scanned over to cassito
delivered it to me was it by Auto pen or
was it the president himself signing it
it was the president
and who obtained that signature
I did
it is odd it is non-standard it is
potentially dangerous I personally
thought it was militarily not feasible
nor wise and I proceeded to tell the
ppos and proceeded to tell
McGregor
that
if I ever saw anything like that
um
I would do something physical
because I thought what that was then was
a tremendous disservice to nation and by
the way that was a very very contested
issue there were people who did not
agree with getting that on Afghanistan I
appreciate their concerns and immediate
the departure
that that memo said would have been a
catastrophic it's the same thing with
President Biden went through it would
have been a debacle
keep in mind the order was for an
immediate withdrawal it would have been
catastrophic and yet president Trump
signed the order
these are the highly consequential
actions of a president who knows his
term will shortly end
at the same time that President Trump
was acknowledging privately that he had
lost the election he was hearing that
there was no evidence of fraud or
irregularities sufficient to change the
outcome
I remember
um
a call all with Mr Meadows
where Mr Meadows was asking me what I
was Finding and if I was finding
anything
and I remember sharing with him that we
weren't finding anything that would be
sufficient to um
change the results in any of the key
States
when was that conversation
probably in November mid to late
November I think it was before my child
was born
and what was Mr Meadow's reaction to
that information
I believe the words he used were so
there's no there there it would be our
job to track it down and and come up dry
because the allegation didn't prove to
be true
and we'd have to you know
relay the news that yeah that that tip
that that you know someone told you
about those those votes uh or that fraud
or you know
nothing came of it
um that would be our job as as
truth-telling uh Squad and you know not
not not a fun job to be you know it's
much it's uh it's an easier job to be
telling the president about you know
wild allegations it's a harder job to be
telling them on the back end that yeah
that's that wasn't true what was
generally discussed on that topic was
whether the fraud male Administration
abuse or irregularities uh if aggregated
and read most favorably to the campaign
would that be outcome determinative
and
um I think everyone's assessment in the
room at least amongst the staff Mark
short myself and Greg Jacob was that it
was not sufficient to be outcome
determined
look it's the right of any candidate to
litigate genuine election disputes
nobody argues that but president Trump's
litigation was completely unsuccessful
in our past hearings we told you that
the committee had identified a total of
62 election lawsuits filed by the Trump
campaign and its allies between November
4th and January 6 of 2021. those cases
resulted in 61 losses
and only a single Victory which did not
affect the outcome for any candidate
the claims were not supported by any
sufficient evidence of fraud or
irregularities
in fact they were baseless as judges
repeatedly recognized
in none of these 62 cases was President
Trump able to establish any viable
claims of election fraud sufficient to
overturn the results of the election
in those hearings we shared with you the
words used by judges around the country
and rejecting the Trump campaign's
claims
it's strong language criticizing the
lack of evidentiary support for the
claims of election fraud in those
lawsuits for example a federal appeals
court in Pennsylvania wrote quote
charges require specific allegations and
proof
we have neither here
a federal judge in Wisconsin wrote quote
the court has allowed the former
president the chance to make his case
and he has lost on the merits
another judge in Michigan called the
claims quote nothing but speculation and
conjecture that votes for president
Trump were either destroyed discarded or
switched to votes for Vice President
Biden
a federal judge in Michigan sanctioned
nine attorneys including Sydney Powell
for making frivolous allegations in an
election fraud case describing the case
as a historic and profound abuse of the
judicial process
recently a group of distinguished
Republican election lawyers former
judges and elected officials issued a
report confirming the findings of the
Courts
in their report entitled lost not stolen
these prominent Republicans analyzed
each election Challenge and concluded
this
Donald Trump and his supporters failed
to present evidence of fraud or
inaccurate results significant enough to
invalidate the results of the 2020
presidential election
on December 11th Trump's allies lost a
lawsuit in the U.S Supreme Court that he
regarded as his last chance as success
in the courts
a newly obtained Secret Service message
from that day shows how angry president
Trump was about the outcome quote just
FYI
Otis is pissed breaking news Supreme
Court denied his lawsuit he is livid now
Cassidy Hutchison an aide Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows was present for that
conversation and described it in this
way
this is the date
this is that case
Mr Meadows and I were in the White House
Residence at a Christmas reception
and as we were walking back from the
Christmas reception that evening the
president was walking out of the Oval
Office so we crossed paths in the Rose
Garden Colonnade
the president was fired up about the
Supreme Court decision and so I was
standing next to somebody Mr Meadows but
I stepped back so I was probably too two
three feet caddy corner from a diagonal
from him the present just raging about
the decision and how it's wrong and why
didn't we make more calls and
just
typical
anger Outburst at this decision and the
president said
so he had said something to the effect
of
I don't want people to know we lost mark
this is embarrassing figure it out we
need to figure it out I don't want
people to know that we lost
our country is a country of laws where
every person including the president
must follow the law and respect the
Judgment of our courts
president Trump's closest advisors held
that view both then and now
well do you believe the President should
abide by the rulings of the Courts
oh yes we we should all comply with the
law at all times to the best of our our
ability every one of us so once the
courts had ruled and the Electoral
College had met
that the election was over in your view
yes I think I think I've said previously
that when the vice president made the
certification and the litigation was
complete
it was complete
when the Electoral College met on the
14th
uh yes as a December 14th is that right
I think that's the right date yes
I assume Pat that you would agree the
president is is uh obligated to abide by
the rulings of the Courts
of course
and and I assume you also would
everybody everybody is obligated to
abide by rules of course
and I assume you also would agree the
president has a particular obligation to
take care that the laws be Faithfully
executed
that is one of the president's
obligations correct
Ivanka do you do you believe the
president's obligated to abide by the
rulings of the Courts
I do
by mid-December of 2020 president
Trump's senior staff were attempting to
persuade him to concede the election
outcome
but but if your question is did I
believe he should concede the election
at a point in time yes I did December
14th was the day that the State
Certified their votes and sent them to
Congress and in my view that was
the end of the matter uh I didn't say
uh you know I thought that
uh this would lead inexorably to a new
Administration I told him that my
personal Viewpoint was that the
Electoral College had met uh which is
the
foreign
system that our country is is said under
to elect a president and vice president
and I believed at that point that the um
means for him to pursue uh litigation
um
was probably closed
and you recall what his response if any
was
he
disagreed
Secretary of Labor Gene Scalia the son
of late Justice Scalia visited president
Trump in mid-December and explained the
situation clearly
and so I had to put a call into the
president I might have called on the
13th we spoke I believe on the 14th in
which
um I conveyed to him that I uh thought
that it was time for him to acknowledge
that President Biden had prevailed
immune election but I communicated to
the president that when that legal
process is exhausted
and
when the electors are have voted
that that's the point at which that
outcome needs to be expected I told him
that I did believe yes that once the
those legal processes were run
uh if fraud had not been established
that had affected the outcome of the
election that unfortunately I believed
that what had to be done was to see the
outcome not only did the courts reject
president Trump's fraud and other
allegations his Department of Justice
appointees including Bill Barr Jeffrey
Rosen and Richard Donahue did as well
president Trump knew the truth
he heard what all his experts and Senior
staff were telling him
he knew he had lost the election
but he made the deliberate choice to
ignore the courts
to ignore the justice department to
ignore his campaign leadership to ignore
senior advisors and to pursue a
completely unlawful effort to overturn
the election
his intent was plain ignore the rule of
law and stay in power Mr chairman I
yield back
gentleman yields back the chair
recognizes John woman from Virginia it's
Lauria
thank you Mr chairman
mid-December was a turning point
president Trump made a decision a choice
to ignore the courts and his advisors
and to push forward to overturn the
election
his efforts to overturn the election
were not random or disconnected whether
they were part of a coordinated
multi-part plan to ensure that he stayed
in power
Donald Trump was the driver behind each
part of this plan he was personally and
directly involved
of course a key element of the plan was
continuing to convince tens of millions
of Americans that he did not in fact
lose
again he did this even though his own
campaign advisors and his Justice
Department officials told him his claims
of fraud were wrong
in this video you'll see that even when
top law enforcement officials told the
president his election fraud claims were
false he still repeated the claims in
the days and weeks that followed
sometimes even the very next
specifically raise the Dominion voting
machines which I found to be among the
most uh disturbing allegations
disturbing in the sense that I saw
absolutely zero basis for the
allegations I told them that it was it
was uh
crazy stuff and they were wasting their
time on that and I was doing a great
great disservice to the country
we have a company that's very suspect
its name is Dominion with the turn of a
dial
for the change of a chip
you can press a button for Trump
and the vote goes to Biden what kind of
a system is this
we definitely talked about Antrim County
again that was sort of done at that
point because the hand recount had been
done and all of that but we cited back
to that to say you know this is an
example of what people are telling you
and what's being filed in some of these
court filings that are just not
supported by evidence and this is the
problem the problem that people keep
telling you these things and they turn
out not to be true
in addition there is the highly
troubling matter of dominion voting
systems
in one Michigan County Alone 6 000 votes
were switched from Trump to Biden and
the same systems are used in the
majority of states in our country
I went into this and
would
you know tell them how crazy some of
these allegations were and how
ridiculous some of them were
uh I'm talking about some of the ones
like you know more votes more absentee
votes were cast in Pennsylvania than
there were absentee ballots requests you
know stuff like that was just easy to
blow up there was never there was never
an indication of
interest
in what the actual facts were
there were more votes than there were
voters think of that you had more votes
than you had voters that's an easy one
to figure
and spy the thousands then he raised the
the big vote dump as he called it in
Detroit
and that you know he said people saw
boxes coming into the counting station
at all hours of the morning and I said
Mr President there are 630 precincts in
Detroit and unlike elsewhere in the
state they centralized the counting
process so they're not counted in each
Precinct they're moved to Counting
stations and so the normal process would
involve boxes coming in at all different
hours
this is Michigan
at 6 31 in the morning
a vote dump of
149 thousand 772
votes came in unexpectedly
with regard to Georgia
where there is no suit
s Fargo and ballots that the suitcase
was rolled out from under the table
and I said no sir there is no suitcase
you can watch that video over and over
there is no suitcase there is a wheeled
bin where they carry the ballots
and that's just how they move balance
around that facility there's nothing
suspicious about that at all
election officials poll boxes Democrats
and suitcases of ballots out from under
a table you all saw it on television
totally fraudulent
this happened over and over again and
our committee's report will document it
purposeful Lies made in public directly
at odds with what Donald Trump knew from
unassailable sources the Justice
Department's own investigations and his
own campaign
Donald Trump maliciously repeated this
nonsense to a wide audience over and
over again his intent was to deceive
president Trump's plan also involved
trying to coerce government officials to
change the election outcome in the
states he lost
he personally reached out to numerous
State officials and pressured them to
take unlawful steps to alter the
election results in those States these
actions taken directly by the president
himself made it clear what his
intentions were to prevent the orderly
transfer of power we all recall for
example president Trump's tape recorded
call with Georgia Secretary of State
Brad raffertzberger
at the time this call occurred president
Trump had already been told repeatedly
by the U.S justice department by his
campaign and by his advisors that his
allegations of fraud in Georgia were
false
so look all I want to do is this I just
want to find
uh
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state look we need
only 11 000 votes we have far more than
that as it stands now we'll have more
and more so what are we going to do here
folks I only need 11 000 votes fellas I
need 11 000 votes give me a break
I just want to find eleven thousand
seven hundred and eighty votes that's an
extraordinary Demand by the president
especially since he already knew from
the justice department there was no
genuine basis for this request
no one could think it would be legal for
the Secretary of State to Simply find
the votes the president needed in order
to win
secretary raffensberger told the
president the truth that he lost the
election in Georgia
but president Trump did not accept that
answer instead he suggested that
secretary raffensberger himself might be
prosecuted
that's a you know that's a criminal
that's a criminal offense and and you
know you can't let that happen that's
that's a big risk to you and to Ryan
your lawyer that's a big risk
we know that President Trump's White
House advisors reacted negatively
immediately after the call Cassidy
Hutchinson had a conversation with Chief
of Staff Mark Meadows
Mark you can't possibly think we're
gonna pull this off like that call was
crazy
and he looked at me and just started
shaking his head and he was like no Cass
you know he knows it's over he knows he
lost but we're gonna keep trying there's
some good options out there still we're
gonna keep trying
Paul and other related activity is now
the focus of an ongoing criminal
investigation in Fulton County Georgia
is not the only state where president
Trump tried to pressure State officials
to change the results
he also attempted to press pressure
State officials in Arizona Pennsylvania
and Michigan to change the results in
those States as well
president Trump was pressuring State
officials he was also trying to use the
Department of Justice to change the
election result
his top officials told him that there
was no evidence to support his claims of
fraud but he didn't care
as he told them
just say the election was corrupt and
leave the rest to me and the Republican
congressman
when these officials would not do what
he said president Trump embarked in an
effort to install Jeff Clark as acting
Attorney General
solely because he he would do what
others in the department would not do we
know that Trump was doing so for a
specific purpose
so Clark could corruptly employ the
Justice Department's authority to help
persuade the states to flip electoral
votes for example when Richard Donahue
and Jeff Rosen both appointed by
President Trump learned of Mr Clark's
proposal here's why they said they
forcefully rejected it
and I recall towards the end saying what
you're proposing is nothing less than
the United States justice department
meddling in the outcome of a
presidential election
but more importantly this was not based
on fact this was actually contrary to
the facts as developed by Department
investigations over the last several
weeks and months
um So I responded to that and for the
Department to insert itself into the
political process this way I think would
have had grave consequences for the
country
it may very well have spiraled us into a
constitutional crisis
we know from our investigation that
President Trump offered Jeff Clark the
position of
a general and that Jeff Clark had
decided to accept it
the only reason this ultimately did not
happen is that the White House Council
and a number of Justice Department
officials confronted the president in
the Oval Office and threatened Mass
resignations
and then
um and I said something effective you're
going to have a huge Personnel blowout
within hours because you're going to
have all kinds of problems with
resignations and other issues
and that's not going to be in anyone's
interest
the president ultimately relented
only because the entire leadership of
the Department of Justice as well as his
White House counsel threatened to resign
Mr chairman I yield back
young woman yields back the chair
recognizes the young woman from Florida
Mrs Murphy for an opening statement
thank you Mr chairman president Trump's
efforts to unlawfully overturn the
results of the 2020 election were not
limited to the big lie in pressuring
State officials and the Department of
Justice officials another key part of
the president's effort was a scheme to
assemble fake electors to cast false
electoral votes in the states to
president Trump lost
this was something done not only with
the president's knowledge but also with
his direct participation
Rana McDaniel chair of the Republican
National Committee testified before this
committee that President Trump and his
attorney Dr John Eastman called her and
asked her to arrange for the fake
electors to meet and rehearse the
process of casting their fake votes
when I received the call
um again I don't remember the exact date
uh it was it was from the White House
wish board
um and and it was President Trump who
had contacted me
and did President Trump have anyone else
on the line with him
um he introduced me to a gentleman named
uh John Eastman so I vaguely remember
him mentioning that he was a professor
and then essentially he turned the call
over to Mr Eastman who then proceeded to
talk about the importance of the RNC
helping the campaign gather these
contingent electors in case any of the
legal challenges
um that were ongoing changed the result
of any updates
these fake electors were ultimately part
of the president's plan to replace
genuine Biden electors with Trump
electors on January 6.
as part of this plan the false electoral
slates were sent to the National
Archives into the capital
the fake elector's plan was also tied to
another plan the coercive pressure
campaign to make vice president Mike
Pence reject or refuse to count certain
Biden electoral votes so that President
Donald Trump would quote win re-election
instead
here is what vice president Pence has
said about this scheme
president Trump said I had the right to
overturn the election
president Trump is wrong
I had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the American
people and the American people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
America
than the notion that any one person
could choose the American president
make no mistake president Trump knew
that what he was demanding vice
president Pence do was illegal he was
informed of this repeatedly and
specifically on January 4th
even his lawyer John Eastman admitted in
front of President Trump that this plan
would break the law by violating the
Electoral count Act
did John Eastman ever admit
as far as you know in front of the
president
at his proposal would violate the
Electoral count Act
uh I believe he did on the fourth
and Dr Eastman confirmed this in writing
recall this email written on January 6
in which vice president Pence's Council
asked Dr Eastman
did you advise the president that in
your professional judgment the vice
president does not have power to decide
things unilaterally
Dr Eastman replied
he's been so advised
of course president Trump's own White
House counsel Pat cipolloni also
recognized that this plan was unlawful
here is Mr cipolloni's testimony
my view as the vice president hadn't
didn't have the legal authority to do
anything except what he did
there is no doubt that President Trump's
pressure campaign on vice president
Pence was significant on the morning of
January 6 president Trump called the
vice president from the Oval Office and
demanded that he overturned the results
of the election
numerous Witnesses told the select
committee about the invective that
President Trump leveled at his own vice
president
something to the effect this is the
wording's wrong
I made the wrong decision four or five
years ago and the the word that she
related to that the president called the
vice president I apologize for being
impolite but do you remember what she
said her father called him the p word
but vice president Pence didn't waver
even when his own life was endangered by
President Trump and the rioters at the
Capitol on January 6th as you'll see in
more detail later
a federal judge concluded based on this
and other evidence that President
Trump's pressure campaign against the
vice president likely violated multiple
criminal statutes in the end all these
people Department of Justice officials
State elections officials his own vice
president
stood strong in the face of President
Trump's immense pressure
but as we now know president Trump had
already summoned tens of thousands of
his supporters to Washington on January
6 to take back their country
on December 19th president Trump first
told his supporters to come to
Washington
in this and numerous other tweets he
fraudulently and repeatedly promoted
January 6 as the day Americans could
come and change the election outcome
for weeks president Trump worked with
others to plan the rally
intending all along that he would send
an assembled crown of angry supporters
to the Capitol after his speech on the
ellipse on January 6.
we obtained a text message that one
rally organizer sent on January 4th in
part it reads that quote POTUS is going
to have us March there slash the capital
and POTUS is going to just call for it
unexpectedly
again each of these examples the big lie
the pressure campaigns against State
officials the pressure campaign against
the Department of Justice and his vice
president the fake electors summoning
the mob all of this demonstrates
president Trump's personal and
substantial role in the plot to overturn
the election
he was intimately involved
he was the central player
thank you Mr chairman and I yield back
General woman yields back
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
California Mr Schiff for an opening
statement
thank you Mr chairman in our past
hearings you have seen direct evidence
that President Trump sent a crowd of his
supporters to the Capitol on January 6th
knowing they were armed and angry
this was the last most desperate and
dangerous prong that was planned to
disrupt The Joint session and prevent
the orderly transition of power
on the morning of the sixth the Secret
Service was at the ellipse screening the
members of the crowd as they entered the
Rally's site
and they noticed something significant
about the crowd
tens of thousands of people were
Excellency
a finance minister of Republic of
Indonesia and of course his Excellency
Governor Perry white Geo committee has
received greater cooperation from the
Secret Service nevertheless Secret
Service text messages from this period
were erased in the days and months
following the attack on the capitol even
though documents and materials related
to January 6th had already been
requested by the Department of Justice
and Congress
but we were able to obtain nearly 1
million emails recordings and other
electronic records from the Secret
Service
over the month of August the select
committee began its review of hundreds
of thousands of pages and multiple hours
of that material providing substantial
new evidence about what happened on
January 6th and the days leading up to
it that review continues what you're
about to hear is just a sample of the
new and relevant evidence that we have
received mounting evidence before
January 6 predicted violence and not
just violence generally but violence
directed at the Capitol
intelligence about this risk was
directly available to the U.S Secret
Service and others in the White House in
advance of the ellipse speech in advance
of the march to the Capitol the
committee has shown evidence that
President Trump was aware of the risk of
violence the FBI U.S Capitol Police
Metropolitan Police and other agencies
all gathered in disseminated
intelligence suggesting the possibility
of violence at the Capitol prior to the
riot we're now going to show you just a
sample of the evidence we have received
days before January 6 the president's
senior advisors at the Department of
Justice and FBI for example received an
intelligence summary that included
material indicating that certain people
traveling to Washington were making
plans to attack the capital
this summary noted online calls to
occupy Federal buildings rhetoric about
invading the Capitol building and plans
to arm themselves and to engage in
political violence at the event
other agencies were also hearing
predictions suggesting possible violence
at the Capitol
on a call of President Trump's White
House national security staff in early
January 2021
deputy secretary of defense David
norquist had warned about the potential
that the capital would be the target of
the attack
here's General Mark milley who was also
present for this call describing deputy
secretary norquist's warning
during these calls I only remember in
hindsight because he was almost like
Clear Point
um
norquist says during one of these calls
the greatest threat is a direct assault
on the capital I'll never forget it
this email for example was an alert that
the Secret Service received on December
24th with the heading armed and ready Mr
President
according to the intelligence multiple
users online were targeting members of
Congress instructing others to March
into the chambers on January 6th and
make sure they know who to fear
in this report received on December 26th
a secret service field office related
tip that had been received by the FBI
according to the source of the tip the
proud boys plan to March armed into DC
they think that they will have a large
enough group to March into DC armed The
Source reported and will outnumber the
police so they can't be stopped
The Source went on to say their plan is
to literally kill people please please
take this tip seriously and investigate
further
The Source also made clear that the
proud boys had detailed their plans on
multiple websites like the donald.win
let's pause here
the Secret Service had Advanced
information more than 10 days beforehand
regarding the proud boys planning for
January 6th
we know now of course that the proud
boys and others did lead the assault on
our Capitol building
on December 31st agents circulated
intelligence reports that President
Trump's supporters proposed a movement
to occupy Capitol Hill
in particular they flagged spikes in
violent hashtags like we are the storm
1776 Rebel and occupy capitals
on January 5th a secret service open
source unit flagged a social media
account on the donald.win that
threatened to bring a sniper rifle to a
rally on January 6th
the user also posted a picture of a
handgun and rifle with a caption Sunday
Gunday providing OverWatch January 6th
will be wild
later on the evening of January 5th the
Secret Service learned during an FBI
briefing that right-wing groups were
establishing armed qrfs or quick
reaction forces readying to deploy for
January 6th
groups like The Oath Keepers were
standing by at the ready should POTUS
request assistance
by invoking the Insurrection act agents
were informed
as we all know now The Oath Keepers did
play a specific role in January 6th and
had stashed weapons in Virginia for
further violence that evening
also on that day the Secret Service was
raiding its security precautions for the
president's speech at the ellipse the
next day
a secret service deputy chief instructed
agents to add certain objects to the
list of items that would be prohibited
at the rally site including ballistic
vests tactical vests armored or not and
Ballistic helmets
by the morning of January 6th it was
clear that the Secret Service
anticipated violence it felt like the
Calm before the storm One agent
predicted in a protective Intelligence
Division chat group
another of Mark how agents were watching
the crazies on live stream
by 909 that morning the Secret Service
could also see that many rally goers
were assembled outside the security
perimeter One agent emailed possibly
because they have stuff that couldn't
come through
would probably be an issue with this
crowd just a thought
by 9 30 that morning
agents reported more than 25 000 people
outside the rally site an hour later the
Secret Service reported that the crowd
was on the mall watching
but not in line
the head of the president's Secret
Service protective detail Robert angle
was specifically aware of the large
crowds outside the magnetometers he
passed that information along to Tony
ornata the work for Mark Meadows in the
chief of staff's office
the documents we obtained from the
Secret Service make clear that the crowd
outside the magnetometers was armed and
the Agents knew it
take a look at what they were seeing in
a hearing on the ground
one report from the rally site at 7 58
a.m said some members of the crowd are
wearing ballistic helmets body armor
carrying radio equipment and
military-grade backpacks
another from 9 30 a.m said that there
were possibly OC spray meaning pepper
spray and or plastic riot shields
at 11 23 a.m agents also reported
possible armed individuals one with a
Glock one with a rifle
over the next hour agents reported
possible man with a gun reported
confirmed pistol on hip located in a
tree and one detained at 14th and I
Street Northwest individual had an
assault rifle on his person
minutes before President Trump began his
speech members of the Federal Protective
Service and agency tasked with
protecting Federal buildings were
alerted about an arrest of a protester
with a gun on his waistband
and during the speech the weapons
related arrests continued
at 12 13 PM United States Park police
arrested a man with a rifle in front of
the World War II Memorial
these agents remarked on the number of
weapons that had been seized that day
speculating that the situation could get
worse
with so many weapons found so far you
wonder how many are unknown what agent
wrote at 12 36 PM could be sporty after
dark
at 12 47 pm
another agent responded no doubt the
people at the ellipse said they are
moving to the Capitol after the POTUS
speech
as the documents we receive make clear
the Secret Service was aware of weapons
possessed by those gathered at rallies
in DC as early as the evening before
take this document for instance which
details multiple arrests and the crowds
demonstrating on January 5th
those arrests were for weapons offenses
handguns high capacity feeding devices
ammunition
what the Secret Service saw on the sixth
was entirely consistent with a violent
rhetoric circulating in the days before
the joint session on pro-trump websites
at times Amplified by the president's
own advisors
on one of these sites as you've heard
one of those was called the donald.win
the [ __ ] committee has obtained a text
message that Jason Miller a senior
Communications advisor sent to Mark
Meadows less than a week before January
6th
I got the bass fired up he wrote in all
caps he sent a link to this page on the
donald.win
the linked web page had comments about
the joint session of Congress on January
6th
take a look at some of those comments
Gallows don't require electricity
if the filthy Kami maggots try to push
their fraud through there will be hell
to pay
our lawmakers in Congress can leave one
of two ways one in a body bag two after
rightfully certifying Trump the winner
Mr Miller claimed that he had no idea
about the hundreds of comments like
these in the link that he sent to Mark
Meadows
if I had seen something like that I
probably would have flipped it to
someone at the white our
if I had seen some of that nature I
would have said we had to flag this for
secret service or something of that
nature
the Trump Administration was aware of
this type of violent record rhetoric
prior to January 6th in fact as we have
seen the Secret Service and other
agencies knew of the prospect of
violence well in advance of the
president's speech at the ellipse
despite this certain White House and
Secret Service Witnesses previously
testified that they had received no
intelligence about violence that could
have potentially threatened any of the
protectees on January 6th including the
vice president
evidence strongly suggests that this
testimony is not credible and the
committee is reviewing additional
material from the Secret Service and
other sources
the Secret Service was monitoring this
kind of online activity and was sharing
and receiving the results of that effort
they work closely with other agencies
sharing intelligence about the joint
session of Congress derived from social
media and other sources
the same day Jason Miller sent his text
message
agents received reports about a spike in
activity on another platform called
parlor this was December 30th
in this email an agent received a report
noting a lot of violent rhetoric on
parlor directed at government people and
entities
including Secret Service protectees
one of these protectees was vice
president Pence perhaps the primary
target of President Trump's pressure
campaign in the days leading up to
January 6th
the day before the joint session on
January 5th Secret Service was aware of
increased chatter focused on vice
president pence in particular whether he
would do what president Trump wanted him
to do reverse the results of the
election in the joint session the next
day January 6th
on the morning of the sixth agents
received alerts of online threats that
vice president Pence would be quote a
dead man walking if he doesn't do the
right thing
another agent reported quote
I saw several other alerts saying they
will storm the capital if he doesn't do
the right thing
the anger reflected in these postings
was obvious the man at the center of the
storm on January 6th president Trump
on the evening of January 5th president
Trump gathered a few of his
Communications staffers in the Oval
Office
the door was open allowing the president
and others assembled there to hear the
sounds of the crowd gathered at Freedom
Plaza just a few blocks from the White
House
president Trump could tell that his
supporters were riled up
here again is Judd dear a deputy Weiss
house a press secretary describing the
president's reaction
he
fairly quickly moved to uh
how fired up the crown is or was going
to be
what did he say about it
um
just that they were they were fired up
they were angry they feel like the
election has been stolen that the
election was rigged that
we went on and on about that for a
little
bit
yes the president knew the crowd was
angry because he had stoked that anger
he knew that they believed that the
election had been rigged and stolen
because he had told them falsely that it
had been rigged and stolen and by the
time he incited that angry mob to march
on the capitol he knew they were armed
and dangerous all the better to stop the
peaceful transfer of power
Mr chairman I yield back
gentleman yields back
at this point out in our meeting will
take a brief recess
pursuant to the order of the committee
of today the chair declares the
committee in recess for a period of
approximately 10 minutes
so it looks like we're going to go to a
break
um I guess we were
going to have an opening statement from
each of
the committee members I have a few
people waiting in the wings here to
bring some commentary uh Texas Paul and
if he's ready there I can bring him in
to see what some of his take was on what
we heard from the committee so far Texas
Paul how are you
uh you're you're muted there my friend
sorry about that my man I didn't want to
leak in anything dude no go ahead go
ahead
I am incredibly as far as a closing
argument goes this has been amazing they
have just really just detailed this out
from beginning to end step to step I was
just I
I can't tell you how impressed I was at
at how sequentially and easy to
understand they have laid this out I
mean from from
the premeditation to all the way through
the execution and I'm sure after after
this break we're going to get the the uh
the
the
reaction during uh you know Trump has
repeatedly lied and said that he wasn't
watching this that he wasn't aware but
we've seen uh releases recently uh from
what him at the ellipse actually
watching the violence take place and
we're gonna probably gonna see some
testimony from folks that he was
watching it at the White House
um it is really
I I just
I'll be honest with you I'm a little
gobsmacked at how good this is being
laid out I just would not want to be
Donald Trump right now
well that's a good point uh Gabe Sanchez
because uh Donald Trump is quiet on
fraud social
um I've been keeping tabs on fraud
social and his social media posts to try
to see if this guy is going to rage post
like he normally does and he has
remained completely silent which is kind
of telling the other news that we have
outside the hearing is that it is likely
that the committee will vote today to
subpoena Donald Trump
um to the committee which uh is
something that has been asked of these
members over and over time and time
again in the media will they subpoena
him and apparently NBC News has obtained
information that yes they are going to
vote to possibly subpoena Donald Trump
but what do you make of some of the news
that the Secret Service knew that the
qrf was there what do you make of that
Mr Sanchez I mean it's uh parts of me
I'm saying it's not surprising obviously
it's I'm surprised that they were able
to or that they did hand over some of
this communication especially since they
were saying oh January 5th and January 6
we just happened to get them lost
because they were deleted during a phone
upgrade but they were able to recover
all these other ones before and after
it's a little suspicious but
the fact that we're hearing this not
surprising considering we know that
communication was going to Tony ornado
that we heard about
um
I feel like we're going to hear more or
at least I hope that we're going to hear
more of that especially as we go into
other other Roger Stone communication
hear more about the documentary but I
mean this doesn't look good I mean we're
finding out more and more details you
know like Texas Paul indicated like
we're getting a good amount during this
hearing because I think for the most
part this might be the very last one
that we get so they're trying to get as
much kind of sound bites Clips audio
whatever you can so that we can show the
American people
what really happened on January 6th so
this is uh I mean there's no there's no
lull so far today and and I'm very
excited and very glad to see that
happening
um but I I will say that I I feel like
there's going to be more that's revealed
after the break I mean this is all
seemed to be kind of leading up to
something as we're kind of we're going
to be climaxing here to a big moment for
the audience to for a bigger reveal
whether it's the vote that happens but I
think as they lead up they're they're
leaving breadcrumbs for everyone that's
watching to follow along and see how
they come to this final conclusion
especially for anyone who's just now
tuning in and never watched one through
eight and is just getting this for day
nine so
that's kind of where I feel like it's
going to go
um but I'm I'm kind of I mean I'm very
excited to see kind of how the second
half of this thing goes well we have
Jessica Denson here as well Jessica
um I'm glad you could join us for this
uh quick break I think they're gonna
take 10 or 15 minutes I think you said
10.
um but uh what was your take so far on
the information
um that the committee has laid out and
this is just their opening statements by
the way which is
um kind of kind of telling of how much
information they may be giving us today
but what's your take so far yeah just
like Texas Paul was saying so methodical
in chronologically laying out the
premeditated plan how many times did you
hear that word premeditated in the
opening I mean I just as I was listening
to Liz Cheney I thought she is
eviscerating any criminal defense that
Donald Trump could possibly have they
they chronologically laid out from prior
to the election how they were planning
on claiming Victory on Election night
regardless of the actual results and
prior to the results coming in you saw
those emails with a a memo that was
drafted that was shared with Donald
Trump everything everything is so
methodical there's always confirmation
that these are not just outside schemers
but that there is actual consent and
um information and feedback given and
received from Donald Trump throughout
this process so they work very
methodically from prior to the election
planning that the election they would
claim the election was Was Won by Donald
Trump before they knew it and if he did
not win and then just following through
on this scheme up until January 6th so I
agree with Gabe I think this is
extremely methodical extremely effective
in doing a lot of the work that the doj
has ahead of them in just
eviscerating any possible defense that
Donald Trump would have establishing
mens rea and um I also am very excited
to see what's about to come in this in
this next segment so on Texas Paul back
to you what do you think
um what do you think about uh the the
possibility of Donald Trump being
subpoenaed and then voting on it today
what do you make of that news as we hear
that
I I think they got that wrong I really
do I mean it would it'd be great theater
and everything but inside baseball is
Garland uh uh Merrick Garland and Benny
Thompson are butting heads I mean like I
mean they are just banging because
Merrick Garland has has been screaming
at them finish this and give me
everything you have
um because they're not handing over
everything that they're working on I
mean the committee is holding on to
testimony and and not providing it to
the doj until they wrap this up and I
think they actually mentioned something
earlier today that this will be the end
of this committee and they will vote on
action
um I don't see them subpoenaing Donald
Trump at all
um I think that's a one of those
corporate news outlets trying to Garner
some attention but I think right now
we're about to see the final summation
their closing argument and then they're
going to vote to refer this to the doj
and drop everything in mayor Garland's
lap and mayor Garland we all know he's
got a 100 conviction rate I mean the man
never misses he never misses but yeah
that's that's what's been going on
behind the scenes Benny Thompson
actually got pretty testy in one
interview uh they asked him you know are
you the doj is asking for information
and he turned around he told the road
reporter and said when we're done with
our work is when they'll get their their
their information and that's that's it I
don't want to hear about this anymore
yeah the beauty the beauty though is
that they don't they don't have to share
this information it's for the whole
world to see so the doj and and we watch
you know we we witnessed this over the
summer watching the doj pick up on
threads from the January 6 hearings
um you know one thing after another as
the January 6th hearing uh committee
were laying these crumbs you would see
some new um subpoena or new action by
the doj so
um it's unfortunate that they're butting
heads but I think the the thing that is
inevitable is that they are laying it
out for the public and the doj is
included and that public and can take
that information
well one thing Gabe is that there is a
difference here between
um this political committee because it
is a political committee it's built
inside our Congress um it is a select
committee it is uh politicians that are
doing it now as as the select committee
pointed out today this is not Democrats
testifying almost every single person
who has testified and gave evidence
um is a republican this is not some kind
of democratic thing that's happening it
is Republicans that are giving this
evidence but
when Merrick garland does get his
evidence regardless of where it comes
from whether it's from their subpoenas
or it is from the sharing of January 6
and I think that's why Benny Thompson
maybe Gabe I mean that's why he's a
little frustrated he's like hey you guys
got more subpoena power than we do so
you'll get our information when we're
done and you can continue your criminal
investigation because it seems to be
that the the select committee is very
sure that there is a whole slew of
crimes that were committed here not just
people going to the Capitol uh
committing violence and and
um you know stealing stuff committing
property damage uh trespassing this is a
lot more than that especially with this
state elective scheme Gabe you know what
I was going to say I mean the other
thing too is you know uh Jessica brings
up a good point is is this is out in the
public right this isn't the public
domain this is very much a court of
public opinion because without this the
American people probably wouldn't know I
mean we know through person no
conversations things we read online that
there's a lot of people that didn't know
really what happened on January 6 or
didn't really it's not even a thing
that's like top of mind for them which
is a very big deal considering when you
have a certain group of people trying to
overthrow a government because they
didn't like the outcome of a fair and
just election and it's just because one
big ketchup throwing plate smashing kind
of guy uh has a tantrum and he doesn't
get the outcome he wants
then he says no no no then nobody gets
this I I'm the one that gets to stay in
power we have a redo the election or I'm
reinstated or whatever kind of [ __ ]
uh ultimatum he makes for the kind of
the position that he's in right and the
other thing here too is like
the committee itself is
is abrogating it is categorizing it is
cross-referencing it is doing everything
for the doj so the doj coming forward
with all these people that they're going
after a lot of that stuff that that the
people that they've already gone after
has been the information that has been
received from from the select committee
and so when Benny Thompson and the
committee hands over everything just
know that they've got you know matrices
that are cross-referencing different
people at different times different
communications video audio everything
has been done for them because we
already know mayor Garland and the rest
of the doj are watching this in real
time they've said that they're following
along so they're I'm sure are taking
notes in terms of like okay cool we got
Mark Meadows talking to Jason Miller or
Jason Miller texting Mark mellow Meadows
about how he's inciting the base and
riling them up like some of the stuff
that we're hearing not only that but I
think the thing that was most shocking
to me early on was hearing how Donald
Trump knew he knew that he lost so he
signed an immediate withdrawal from
Somalia in Afghanistan as like a we're
going to own the libs and hand off this
failure over to Biden and so that is a
clear sign that a guy has given up
doesn't want to deal with it he's like
not my problem it's for the next guy
meeting Biden as they said and not only
that I just want to bring up the day
that he signed that was November 11th
2020. that is Veterans Day that is the
ultimate middle finger to a group of
people that the Republican Party says oh
we we greatly admire the service and the
the things that you do to protect us but
in that same breath we'll give them a
middle finger to say ah you guys can go
f yourselves and we don't really care
about you
so even even that like Not only was that
a a disgusting vile move by Trump but
also shows you that the guy knew it was
over and he was trying to push this
stuff off of his slate onto the next
person to show that he was done uh Ben
myzealous
um you it seems like you have some um
some friends there with you um what what
did you make of the I I it struck me
that Rona McDaniel took a phone call
where Donald Trump they were going to
practice the coup attempt with the state
electors what do you make of that piece
of uh that nugget that came out of
nowhere almost well they're going right
here now to the criminal prosecution
component of it right like this is
almost certainly going to be the last
January 6th Committee hearing before the
midterms and they are making a case not
just to the general public right now but
they're making a case to the doj and
even though they don't have the power as
the January 6 committee to prosecute
they're saying here is the Criminal
Intent
um element
um and Gabe to your point it's not just
passing along the buck to the next
Administration it was actually
sabotaging the next Administration by
trying to harm and let's just be clear
trying to kill our troops and put our
veterans In Harm's Way as a way as you
said you know to own the libs or to Owen
Biden but to actually sabotage it rather
than come with a clear plan of
transitioning the troops out an
immediate emergency withdrawal that
would become Biden's problem and would
be an Fu to the military as well into
the command structure there so a lot of
a lot of insightful things but obviously
the message here is one of Criminal
Intent that is what there's that's the
message they're sending and then we're
also learning that at the end of it
today we should be having uh the you
know because it's a special session of
the committee it's a little bit of a
different technical uh assembly of the
session they have the referral power
based on how they're currently
constituted and we're learning they're
going to refer subpoena
that be sent to Donald Trump and command
Donald Trump appear before the committee
as kind of the the last act and kind of
a put up or shut up Donald Trump you
want to come here and and chat we're
going to subpoena you and so I think
that's what we're going to see this also
build up to as well towards the end well
um I I can't wait and again we're still
waiting uh we're still on break here as
everyone can see our screen is just
showing the slide there
um I want to go back to Texas Paul for a
second Texas Paul you had something you
wanted to say
yeah and and remember the first day when
you asked me what did I what what I
thought Liz Cheney was going to do
yeah and I told you that she's gonna
burn their house down and go in at night
and piss on the ashes
that is what she's doing
guy investigators this whole butting
heads about with the doj I don't mean I
don't know I have to cut you up I have
to get y'all we're going back to the
hearing aided
[Laughter]
God was angry
he knew that they were armed and
dangerous
and he knew that they were going to the
Capitol
it's important to understand the lengths
the president was willing to go to
physically be at the Capitol because it
was part of his strategy to disrupt
Congress and to stay in power
is the time for the ellipse rally
approached an email was circulated among
intelligence officials including Secret
Service intelligence official attaching
Communications among rally goers that
specifically contemplated violence
Trump has given us marching orders one
post on the donald.wind wrote basically
if you're east of the Mississippi you
can and should be there
Advance on the capitol
keep your guns hidden don't [ __ ] around
full kits 180 rounds minimum for main
rifle another 50 for sidearm per person
what is clear from this record is that
the White House had more than enough
warning to Warrant stopping any plan for
an ellipse rally and certainly for
stopping any March to the Capitol
and as evidence from our prior hearings
has suggested the president was aware of
this information
but despite awareness of the potential
for violence and weapons among the crowd
the ellipse event nevertheless went
forward and Donald Trump instructed The
Angry Crowd some of whom were armed to
March to the Capitol
as my colleague Mr Schiff just described
the Secret Service reported that
thousands in the crowd near the
Washington Monument would not enter the
rally area because magnetometers used in
screening attendees
would it detect any prohibited items
They Carried
Mr Trump knew this
his secret service had told him about it
that morning
even in spite of These Warnings Cassidy
Hutchinson overheard the president say
this shortly before he took stage
he wanted it full and he was angry that
we weren't letting people through the
mags with weapons
what the Secret Service teams as weapons
and our
our weapons I was in the vicinity of a
conversation where I overheard the
president say something to the effect of
you know I don't I think care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing bags away let my people in they
can March the capital from here let the
people in take the acting mags away
and when he went on stage president
Trump himself asked law enforcement to
let his supporters in the rally site
[Music]
the military the Secret Service and we
want to thank you and the police law
enforcement great you're doing a great
job
but I'd love it if they could be allowed
to come up here with us is that possible
can you just let them come up please
president Trump then told his supporters
to March to the Capitol
let's pause at this point to consider
president Trump's State of Mind
his motivation at this moment
by that point it was known to Secret
Service that members of the crowd were
armed
president Trump had been told and there
was no doubt that President Trump knew
what he was going to do sending an angry
mob a number of whom were clad in
tactical gear and Military Garb armed
with various weapons to the Capitol
there's no scenario where that action is
benign
and there's no scenario where an
American president should have engaged
in that conduct
it did not matter whether president
Trump believed the election had been
stolen or not this could not be
justified on any basis for any reason
you may also recall testimony from our
summer hearings regarding Mr Trump's
efforts to lead the mob to the capital
himself in his angry altercation in the
presidential SUV when the Secret Service
told him it was far too dangerous for
him to go
is we detailed in testimony from the
Metropolitan Police and White House
Personnel during our July 21st hearing
information about altercation was widely
known
so widely known that one former White
House employee with National Security
responsibilities explained that this
information was in fact water cooler
talk in the White House complex
is that professional told us they
remember hearing in the days after
January 6th how angry the president was
when he was in a limo that afternoon
that professional also testified that
they were specifically informed of the
president's irate behavior in the SUV by
Mr ornado in Mr Renato's office
it was Mr Engel
with Mr ornado in that office
they'd expressed to me that the
president was irate you know on the
drive up
Mr Engel did not deny the fact that the
president was irate
that of course corresponds closely with
the testimony you saw this summer from
Cassidy Hutchinson a metropolitan police
officer who's in the motorcade and for
multiple sources
additionally after concluding its review
of the voluminous additional Secret
Service Communications from January 5th
and January 6th the committee will be
recalling Witnesses and conducting
further investigative depositions based
on that material
following that activity we will provide
even greater detail in our final report
and I will also note this
the committee is reviewing testimony
regarding potential obstruction on this
issue including testimony about advice
given not to tell the committee about
this specific topic
we will address this matter in our
report
we also want to remind you now of how
Security Professionals working in the
White House complex and who reported to
National Security officials responded
when they learned that Mr Trump intended
to lead the mob to the Capitol
to be completely honest you were all in
the state of town
because why
because it's just
one I think the actual physical
feasibility of doing it and then also we
all knew about and what that meant that
this was no longer a rally that this was
going to move to something else which we
physically walked to the capital
I I don't know if you want to use the
word Insurrection who whatever we all
knew that this would move from a normal
Democratic you know public event into
something else why were we alarmed right
the president wanted to leave tens of
thousands of people to the Capitol
um I think that was enough grounds for
us to be alarmed
president Trump was still considering
traveling to the Capitol even after
returning to the White House
he knew well before 2PM that a violent
Riot was underway at the Capitol
he was aware of the ongoing lawlessness
but his motorcade was held on West
Executive Avenue outside the white house
because he still wanted to join the
crowd
here's Kaylee mcineny the White House
Press Secretary describing an exchange
she had with the president as soon as he
arrived back at the White House
so to the best of my recollection I
recall him being
wanting to saying that he wanted to
physically walk and be a part of the
March and then saying that uh he would
ride the Beast if if he needed to right
in the presidential limo
from the Secret Service the select
committee is also obtained important new
evidence on this issue
it shows how frantic this hour must have
been for the Secret Service scrambling
to get the president of the United
States to back down from a dangerous and
Reckless decision
that put People In Harm's Way
take a look at the Secret Service email
from 1 19 pm on January 6th the minute
that President Trump got out of the
presidential vehicle back at the White
House
as soon as the president left his
motorcade leadership from the Secret
Service contacted Bobby Engel the lead
agent for the presidential detail and
warned him that they were quote
concerned about an OTR an off the Record
movement to the Capitol
the people sworn to protect the safety
of the president of the United States
and who routinely put themselves In
Harm's Way were convinced that this was
a bad idea
Secret Service documents also reveal how
agents were poised to take president
Trump to the Capitol later that
afternoon
agents were instructed to Don their
protective gear and prepare for a
movement a few minutes later they were
told the president would leave for the
Capitol in two hours
wasn't until 1 55 PM that the
president's lead secret service agent
told them to stand down we are not doing
an OTR to the Capitol
by then rioters had breached the capital
and were violently attacking the efforts
of the brave men and women in law
enforcement trying to resist the mob
president Trump may not have gone to the
Capitol on January 6th but what he did
from the White House cannot be justified
while Congressional leaders both
Democrats and Republicans
worked with vice president Pence to try
and address the violence
president Trump refused urgent pleas for
help from nearly everyone around him
and what he did do only made the
situation worse
Mr chairman I yield back
the gentleman yields back the chair
recognizes the gentleman from Maryland
Mr Raskin for an opening statement thank
you Mr chairman
the president was still exhorting his
supporters at the ellipse to go fight
like hell at 12 50 around the time that
the first wave of rioters first breached
barricades defending the capital
Secret Service documents we recently
received give a timeline of precisely
what the White House knew and when
at 119 the president's Emergency
Operations Center sent an email to
Secret Service National Security and
Military advisors to the President and
Vice President informing them that quote
hundreds of trump supporters stormed
through metal barricades at the back of
the Capitol building about 1 pm
Wednesday running past security guards
and breaking fences
when the president returned to the White
House around 1 20 he entered the Oval
Office and was told right then about the
onset of violence at the Capitol from
that point until approximately 4 pm over
the next two hours and 40 minutes the
president stayed in the White House
dining room attached to the Oval Office
and watched this unprecedented assault
take place at the Capitol
we have testimony from several members
of the President's White House staff
establishing that President Trump
refused in treaties from his closest
advisors and family members to tell his
supporters to stand down and leave the
capitol here's the testimony of
President Trump's White House counsel
Pat cipolloni
I can't talk about conversations with
the president but I can generically say
that I said you know people need to be
told there needs to be a public
announcement fast
that they need to leave the capitol
approximately when almost immediately
after I found out people were getting
into the capital or approaching the
capital in a way that was was violent
you on the staff
did not want people to leave the capital
on the staff
in the white house and I I
can't think of anybody
you know on that day we didn't want
people to get out of the
the Capital One particularly wants a
violence started no
I mean
what about the president yeah
look she said to staff
so I answered no I said in the White
House
oh I'm sorry I apologize I thought you
said who who else on the staff
I I can't reveal Communications but
obviously I think
you know
yeah
Mr cipolloni's testimonies corroborated
by multiple other White House staff
members including Cassidy Hutchinson
here's Ms Hutchinson describing what she
heard from Mark Meadows
he uh has said something
to the effect of you know you heard him
Patty he doesn't want to do anything
more he doesn't think they're doing
anything wrong
a former White House employee with
National Security Duty similarly
recalled an exchange between Mr
cipolloni and Eric Hershman about
President Trump's inaction against the
mob assault underway at the Capitol
Mr Hershman said something to Mr
cipolloni he seemed to relay that you
know the president didn't want anything
done
throughout this period some of the
president's most important political
allies family members and Senior staff
all begged him to tell his supporters to
disperse and go home they included Sean
Hannity Laura Ingram and other allies at
Fox News his son Donald Trump Jr the
House minority leader Kevin McCarthy
others in Congress and officials in the
cabinet in the executive branch all of
them made appeals to Donald Trump which
he rejected and he ignored the select
committee interviewed several people who
were in the dining room with Donald
Trump that afternoon and every single
one of these Witnesses told us that he
was watching the violent battles rage on
television he did not call his secretary
of defense or the National Guard the
chief of the Capitol Police or the chief
of the Metropolitan Police Department
and to your knowledge was the president
in that private dining room the whole
time that the attack on the capitol was
going on or did he ever go again only to
your knowledge to the Oval Office to the
White House Situation Room anywhere else
so that's my recollection he was always
in the dining room what did they say Mr
Meadows are the president
and all during that Brief Encounter that
you were at the time what do you I think
everybody was watching the TV do you
know whether he was watching TV in the
dining room when you talked to him on
January 6th
um it's my understanding he was watching
television
when you were in the dining room in
these discussions was the font was the
violence of the capital visible on the
screen
yes
does the president watched the bloody
attack unfold on Fox news from his
dining room members of Congress and
other government officials stepped into
the gigantic leadership void created by
the president's chilling and studied
passivity that day what you're about to
see is previously unseen footage of
congressional leaders both Republicans
and Democrats is they were taken to a
secure location during the riot you'll
see how everyone involved was working
actively to stop the violence to get
federal law enforcement deployed to the
scene to put down the violence and
secure the capital complex not just
Democrats like speaker Nancy Pelosi and
House Majority Leader steny Hoyer but
Republicans like vice president Pence
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
majority whip John thune in countless
other appointees across the
administration all of them did what
president Trump was not doing what he
simply refused to do take a listen
we're starting to get surrounded they're
taking the North Front scaffolding
if we're gaining
absence
yesterday
[Applause]
Senator Schumer is at a secure location
and they're locked down in the Senate
there has to be some way we can maintain
the sense that people have
that there's a some security or some
confidence
that government can function and that we
can elect the president of the United
States
did we go back into session
did go back into session but apparently
everybody on the floor is putting onto
your gas masks to prepare for a beach
I'm trying to get more information
they're putting on their tear gas masks
we need a area for the housing members
they're all walking over now through the
tunnels
we have some Senators who are still in
their hideaways they need massive
Personnel now can you get the Maryland
National Guard to come to I have
something to say Mr secretary well I'm
going to call of the mayor of Washington
D.C right now and see what other
Outreach she has to other police
departments our leader employer has
mentioned
[Music]
uh I don't know if you have been
approached about the Virginia National
Guard Mr Hoya was to connect I'm
speaking to uh Governor Hogan but I
still think you probably need the okay
of the
federal government in order to come into
another jurisdiction
thank you
oh my gosh they're just breaking windows
they're doing all all kinds of it's
really that somebody they said somebody
was shot it's just it's just horrendous
and all at the instigation of the
president of the United States
okay thank you Governor I appreciate
what they're doing and if you don't mind
the life just stay in touch thank you
going through sometimes Virginia God is
uncalled in you know I'm just talking to
Governor Northam and what he said is
they sent 200 of State Police
and a unit of the National Guard
they're breaking windows and going in uh
uh obviously ransacking our offices and
all the rest of that that's nothing
the concern we have about uh personal
safety personal safety is it just
transcends everything but the fact is on
any given day they're breaking the law
in many different ways and quite frankly
much of it at the instigation of the
president of the United States
and now if he could could at least uh
somebody yeah why don't you get the
president to tell them to leave the
capital Mr attorney general and your law
enforcement responsibility a public
statement they should all leave
[Music]
us
this cannot be just for waiting for so
and so we need them there now whoever
you got that you also have troops this
is
Andrews Air Force Base all right other
military bases thank you we need active
duty National Guard how soon in the
future can you have the place evacuated
you know cleaned out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
to just one complaint Arizona and then
we could vote and that would be you know
then just move forward with the rest of
the state
overriding wish is to do it at the
Capitol what we are being told very
directly is it's going to take days for
the capital to be okay again we've
gotten a very bad report about the
conditions of the
um house floor for the defecation and
all that kind of thing as well I don't
think that that's hard to clean up but I
do think it is more from a security
standpoint of making sure that everybody
is out of the building and how long will
that take I just got off the device
fence and I got off with the vice
president-elect
okay but what we left the conversation
with because he said he had the
impression for Mitch that Mitch wants
everybody back to do it there yes I said
well we're getting a Counterpoint that
is could take time to clean up the poo
poo that they're making all over the
literally and figuratively in the
capital and that that may take days to
get back
of uh
the U.S Capitol Police he just informed
me what you will hear Through official
channels Paul Irving yourself
we'll inform you that their best
information is that they believe
the house in the Senate will be able
to
[Music]
good news
thank you
in this video you just saw Senator Chuck
Schumer urging acting attorney general
Jeff Rosen to get president Trump to
call off the Riders of course acting A.G
Rosen did take action to defend the
government as did many other officials
but Congressional leadership recognized
on a bipartisan basis that President
Trump was the only person who could get
the mob to end its violent Siege of the
Congress leave the capital and go home
here's Senator McConnell speaking after
January 6 about how president Trump
abandoned his duties and failed to do
his job
it was obvious
that only President Trump
could end this
he was the only one
who could
former aides publicly begged him to do
so
loyal allies frantically called the
administration
the president did not act swiftly
he did not do his job
he didn't take steps so federal law
could be Faithfully executed
and Order restored
no
in the midst of this violent chaos Kevin
McCarthy implored Donald Trump to tell
his supporters in the mob to leave the
Capitol and when that didn't work
McCarthy called Trump's adult children
to try to get them to intercede with
Trump to call off the insurrectionary
violence in our prior hearings we showed
you a description of what McCarthy told
Republican congresswoman Jamie Herrera
Butler about his conversation with Trump
during the violence another witness Mick
Mulvaney president Trump's former Chief
of Staff has also come forward and
corroborated her shocking account
do I asked Kevin McCarthy who's the
Republican leader about this
um and he said he called Donald G
finally got through to Donald Trump and
he said you have got to get on TV you've
got to get on Twitter you've got to call
these people off you know what the
president said to him this is as it's
happening he said well Kevin these are
my people you know these are these are
in FIFA and Kevin responded and said no
they're your people they literally just
came through my office windows and my
staff were running for cover I mean
they're running for their lives you need
to call them off and the president's
response to Kevin to me was
he said well Kevin I guess they're just
more upset about the election uh you
know fast than you are and that's you
know you've seen widespread reports of
Kevin McCarthy and the president having
a basically a swearing conversation
that's when the swearing sets because
the president was basically saying nah I
I'm okay with this
um I had I had a conversation at some
point
in the day or week after uh the uh the
riot with Kevin yeah it was very similar
to what Jamie had the conversation she
had retold about how he called and asked
the president to get them to stop and
the president told them something along
the lines of together maybe these people
are just more angry about this than you
are maybe more upset I had the
conversation similar to that with Kevin
in the day to week after after you write
and we know how Kevin McCarthy described
president Trump's conduct both in public
and in private
the president Bears responsibility for
Wednesday's attack on Congress by mob
rioters he should have immediately
denounced the mob when he saw what was
unfolding
these facts require immediate action of
President Trump
accept his share of responsibility quell
the Brewing unrest and ensure
president-elect Biden is able to
successfully begin his term
but let me be very clear to all of you
and I've been very clear to the
president
he Bears responsibilities for his
foreigns or buts I asked him personally
today does he hold responsibility for
what happened
does he feel bad about what happened he
told me he does have some responsibility
for what happened
um
and he need to acknowledge that
2 24 p.m knowing the deadly Riot was now
bearing down on his own vice president
president Trump composed and sent to
tweet attacking vice president Pence
accusing him of cowardice for not
unilaterally rejecting Electoral College
votes for Joe Biden and simply handing
Trump to presidency the impact of that
tweet was foreseeable and predictable it
further inflamed the mob which was
chanting hang Mike Pence and provoked
them to even greater violence this
deliberate decision to further enrage
the mob against vice president Pence
cannot be justified by anything that
President Trump might have thought about
the election
the Tweet came precisely at the time
Pence's Secret Service detail was most
seriously concerned for the vice
president's physical safety we've
obtained new documents from the Secret
Service real-time chats that underscore
the threat they knew the vice president
would be facing because of the
president's escalating incitement of the
mob
after Trump's tweet One agent in the
secret service's Intelligence Division
immediately warned POTUS just tweeted
about Pence probably not going to be
good for Pence
another agent reported the dramatic
impact of Trump's anti-pence tweet on
his followers POTUS said he lacked
courage over 24
000 likes in under two minutes employees
at Twitter were nervously monitoring the
situation they knew that certain Twitter
users were riding at the Capitol and
tweeting about it at the same time as
the afternoon progressed the company
detected a surge in violent hashtags on
the platform including lines of lethal
incitement like execute Mike Pence
listen to this former Twitter employee
Anika navaroli who first came to the
committee anonymously but is now bravely
agreed to be named because she wants to
speak out about the magnitude of the
threats facing our people
and you're also seeing content on the
platform at that time
um that was
threatening towards the vice president
hashtag excuse they were literally
calling first execution as this week was
going up yes
after in response to this week too
because I think as as many of as many of
Donald Trump's tweets did it again
with the individuals who were already
constructing Gallows who were already
willing and able of wanting to execute
someone and looking for someone to be
killed now the individual was called
upon them to begin this coup is now
pointing the finger
add another individual
um while they're ready
here's a small sample of the reactions
that President Trump's fan the Flames
tweet provoked among capital rioters in
real time
what percentage of the crowd has gone to
the Capitol 100 that is that it is
spread like wildfire that Pence has
betrayed us and everybody's marching on
the capital all million of us it's
insane
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
between 2 30 and 235 within 10 minutes
of President Trump's tweet thousands of
riders overran the line that the
metropolitan police forces civil
disturbance unit was holding on the west
side of the Capitol this was the first
time in the history of the Metropolitan
Police Department that is security line
like that had ever been broken president
Trump's conduct that day was so shameful
and so outrageous that it prompted
numerous members of The White House
staff and other Trump appointees to
resign in Prior hearings you've heard
Deputy National Security adviser Matt
pottinger and Deputy White House Press
Secretary Sarah Matthews explained why
they felt compelled to resign on that
day since then we've spoken to more
high-ranking officials like President
Trump's Envoy to Northern Ireland and
former Chief of Staff Mick Mulvaney in
transportation secretary Elaine Chao who
resigned after the sixth in protest of
Trump's misconduct and to dissociate
themselves from his role in the violence
take a listen to what they had to say
I was stunned by violence
and uh was stunned by the president's
apparent
indifference to the violence and now is
the time for the president presidential
I thought he failed at doing it I
thought he failed and I had a critical
time to be the sort of leader that the
nation needed I think the events at the
Capitol
however they occurred
were shocking and it was something that
as I mentioned in my statement that I
could not put aside and at a particular
point the events were such that it was
impossible for me to continue given my
personal values and My Philosophy I came
as an immigrant to this country I
believe in this country
I believe in a peaceful transfer of
power I believe in democracy
and so
I was a it was a decision that I made on
my own
when security assistance began to arrive
at the Capitol and the tide turned
against the Insurrection president Trump
finally gave his painfully belated
instruction at 4 17 PM so after multiple
hours of rioting and more than a hundred
serious injuries suffered by our Law
Enforcement Officers the crowd finally
began to disperse listen carefully to
what they said as they decided to leave
the capitol
we are delivering the president's
message
[Music]
[Music]
he says go home
[Music]
finally it's 601 president Trump tweeted
again not to condemn the mass violence
in any way but rather to excuse and
glorify it significantly he made it
clear that he considered the violence
perfectly foreseeable and predictable
check it out
these are the things and events that
happen when a sacred Landslide election
Victory is so unceremoniously viciously
Stripped Away from great Patriots who
have been badly unfairly treated for so
long these are the things that happened
he said giving the whole game away Trump
was telling us that the vice president
the Congress and all the injured and
wounded cops some of whom are with us
today got what was coming to us
according to Trump January 6 should not
be a day that lives in shame and infra
infamy in our history but rather in
glory remember this day forever he wrote
proudly as if he were talking about
D-Day or the Battle of Yorktown Trump
did nothing to stop the deadly violence
for obvious reasons he thought it was
all Justified he incited it and he
supported it
would it have been possible at any
moment for the president to walk down to
the podium in the briefing and talk to
the nation at any time between when you
first gave him a device at two o'clock
in 417 when video statement
would that have been possible it would
have been possible yes yes
the president had wanted to make a
statement and address the American
people he could have been on camera
almost instantly and conversely the
White House Press Corps has offices that
are located directly behind the briefing
room and so if he had wanted to make an
address from the Oval Office we could
have assembled the White House Press
Corps probably in a matter of minutes to
get them into the oval for him to do an
on-camera address
Mr chairman
nothing in law or fact could justify the
president's failure to act
and we also would agree the president
has to take their obligation to take
care that the laws be Faithfully
executed
that's why the president's office
Mr chairman in numerous places our
constitution strongly opposes
Insurrection and Rebellion Article 1
gives Congress the power to call forth
the militia to suppress insurrections
Section 3 of the 14th Amendment
disqualified from holding federal and
state office anyone who has sworn an
oath to defend the Constitution but
betrays it by engaging in Insurrection
or Rebellion it was President Lincoln at
the start of the Civil War in 1861 who
best explained why democracy rejects
Insurrection Insurrection he said is a
war upon the first principle of popular
government the rights of the people
American democracy belongs to all the
American people not to a single man
thank you Mr chairman I yield back
the gentleman yields back
during this committee's first Hearing in
July of last year our Witnesses were
full police officers who helped repel
the Riots of January 6. we asked them
what they hope to see the committee
accomplish over the course of our
investigation
officer Grinnell wanted to know why the
rioters were made to believe that the
election process was rigged
officer for known asked us to look into
the actions and activities that resulted
in the day's events officer Hodges was
concerned about whether anyone in power
had a role
officer Dunn put it simply
get to the bottom of what happened
we've worked for more than a year to get
those answers we've conducted more than
a thousand interviews and depositions we
received and reviewed hundreds of
thousands of pages of documents thanks
to the tireless work of our members and
investigators we've left we have left no
doubt none that Donald Trump LED an
effort to up in American democracy that
directly resulted in the violence of
January 6th
he tried to take away the voice of the
American people in choosing their
president and replaced the will of the
voters with his will to remain in power
he is the one person at the center of
the story of what happened on January 6.
so he wanted to hear from him the
committee needs to do everything in our
power to tell the most complete story
possible and provide recommendations to
help ensure nothing like January 6th
ever happens again
we need to be fair and thorough and gain
a full context for the evidence we've
obtained
but the need for this committee to hear
from Donald Trump's goes beyond our fact
finding this is a question about
accountability to the American people
he must be accountable
he is required to answer for his actions
he's required to answer to those police
officers who put their lives and bodies
on the line to defend our democracy he's
required to answer to those millions of
Americans who votes he wanted to throw
out as part of his scheme to remain in
power
and whatever is underway to ensure this
accountability on the law this committee
will demand a full accounting to every
American
person of the event of January 6. so it
is Our obligation to seek Donald Trump's
testimony
there's precedent in American history
for Congress to compel the testimony of
a president president
that's also precedent for presidents to
provide testimony and documentary
evidence to Congressional investigators
we also recognize that a subpoena to a
former president is a serious and
extraordinary action
that's why we want to take this step in
full view of the American people
especially because the subject matter at
issue is so important to the American
people and the stakes are so high for
our future and our democracy
and so I recognize the vice chair Ms
Cheney of Wyoming to offer a motion
Mr chairman pursuant to today's notice I
send to the desk a committee resolution
and ask for its immediate consideration
the clerk will report the resolution
committee resolution one resolved that
the chairman B and is hereby directed to
subpoena Donald J Trump for documents
and testimony in connection with the
January 6th attack on the United States
Capitol pursuant to section 5c4 of house
resolution 503 and Clause 2m of rule 11
of the rules of the House of
Representatives
the young woman from Wyoming is
recognized on her resolution
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman our
committee now has sufficient information
to answer many of the critical questions
posed by Congress at the outset we have
sufficient information to consider
criminal referrals for multiple
individuals
and to recommend a range of legislative
proposals to guard against another
January 6th
but a key task remains
we must seek the testimony under oath of
January 6th Central player
more than 30 Witnesses in our
investigation have invoked their Fifth
Amendment right against
self-incrimination
and several of those did so specifically
in response to questions about their
dealings with Donald Trump directly
here are a few examples this is Roger
Stone with Oath Keepers at the Willard
Hotel on the morning of January 6th
and here is Mr Stone testifying before
our committee
once again on advice of council I will
assert my Fifth Amendment right to
respectfully decline to answer your
question
this is General Michael Flynn walking
with Oath Keepers on December 12 2020
and here is General Flynn's testimony
before our committee
did you General Flynn talk to president
Trump
at any point on January 6 2021
the fifth
here is John Eastman fraudulently
instructing tens of thousands of angry
protesters that the vice president could
change the election outcome on January
6th
later on this same day Dr Eastman
acknowledged in writing that Donald
Trump knew what he was attempting was
illegal
here is John Eastman testifying before
our committee
president Trump authorized you to
discuss publicly or January 4th 2021
conversation with him if
so is it your position that you can
discuss in the media direct
conversations you had with the president
of the United States but you will not
discuss those same conversations with
this committee if
here is Jeff Clark
who conspired with Donald Trump to
corrupt the Department of Justice
president Trump wanted to appoint Jeff
Clark as acting attorney general and as
you can see in this call log we obtained
from the National Archives he did so
and here is Mr Clark testifying before
our committee
Mr Clark when did you first talk
directly with President Trump
fifth
Mr Clark did you discuss with President
Trump allegations of fraud in the 2020
election
fifth
other Witnesses have also gone to
enormous lengths to avoid testifying
about their dealings with Donald Trump
Steve Bannon has been tried and
convicted by a jury of his peers for
contempt of congress he is scheduled to
be sentenced for this crime later this
month
criminal proceedings regarding Peter
Navarro continue
and Mark Meadows Donald Trump's former
Chief of Staff has refused to testify
based upon executive privilege the
committee's litigation with him
continues
Mr chairman at some point the Department
of Justice May well unearth the facts
that these and other Witnesses are
currently
concealing
but our duty today is to our country and
our children and our constitution
we are obligated to seek answers
directly from the man who set this all
in motion and every American is entitled
to those answers so we can act now to
protect our Republic
so this afternoon I am offering this
resolution
that the committee direct the chairman
to issue a subpoena
for Relevant documents and testimony
under oath from Donald John Trump
in connection with the January 6th
attack on the United States capital
thank you Mr chairman I yield back
Senator yields back if there's no
further debate the question that is on
agreeing to the resolution those in
favor will say aye
aye aye those opposes no
in the opinion of the chair the eyes
have it Mr chairman I request a recorded
vote
a recorded vote is requested the clerk
will call the roll
Miss Cheney
aye Miss Cheney aye
Ms Lofgren
aye Ms Lofgren aye
Mr Schiff
aye Mr Schiff aye
Mr Aguilar
aye Mr Aguilar aye
Mrs Murphy
aye Mrs Murphy aye
Mr Raskin
aye Mr Raskin aye
Mrs Lauria
aye this is Lauria aye Mr kensinger
kensinger I Mr kensinger aye Mr chairman
aye Mr chairman aye
the clerk will report the vote
Mr chairman on this vote there are nine
eyes and zero no's
the resolution is agreed to without
objection a motion to reconsider is laid
on the table
the chair request that those in the
hearing room remain seated until a
Capitol Police have escorted members
from the room
without objection the committee stands
adjoined
so there you have it
it came to
a
very
close there
um with a vote to subpoena Donald Trump
um
I don't know if you've heard of a Cheney
drone strike but um
it seems as if they used Liz Cheney in a
way
that would send the biggest signal
as they were closing up I was checking
uh Donald Trump's social media platform
I you know it as I call it here uh fraud
social
um on my show
but he is currently he's been silent he
was silent for about 18 hours he was not
posting anything and he as he was being
subpoenaed by the January 6th select
hearing Donald Trump was tweeting
are posting excuse me on Truth social
about JD Vance
um so it appears that he is not taking
it seriously now we had some commentary
at the break
about this subpoena from uh minus Mighty
favored Texas Paul and he was messaging
me in the chat when they were
subpoenaing him um I think he was just
laughing out loud I'm not sure whether
it was that himself or at the situation
um but I informed him that Liz Cheney
was gonna come get him so let's bring in
Texas Paul for a minute to answer for
his for his commentary Texas Paul you're
you're on mute but yeah um go ahead sir
if you can unmute and tell us what you
make of the subpoena
I was wrong I didn't think they were
going to go to this step I was wrong and
I laughed so freaking hard when Benny
Thompson said
and the co-chair I was like oh my God
that is perfect that is perfect I mean
she just went
I mean it was great it was great I mean
I literally I had tears in my eyes I was
laughing so hard because you know I
don't give a damn how Trump is trying to
pretend like oh I'm gonna talk about JD
Vance he is dying inside he is just
dying inside
I loved it I loved it I did I could I I
literally laughed I had white tears away
I was laughing so I was watching you I
was watching in the green room as your
reaction to
um what was happening at the hearing
where they were voting and I um just to
let the audience know as we're as we're
coming to a close here on the hearing I
am going to be watching
um uh in in the background because
sometimes we have Jamie Raskin or um we
might have Adam shipped or some other a
select member committee members who
might speak so I'll be watching that so
if I cut in it is because someone is
speaking uh Gabe Sanchez
um Texas Paul is apologizing for his uh
misstep there but what do you make what
do you make of not just that they're
subpoenaing down Trump because we we
heard that was the news even though Paul
didn't exactly believe it but here's
what I'll tell you the the video about
Nancy Pelosi
um it absolutely destroyed is The
Narrative of that she was doing nothing
and that she it's all her fault when it
is obvious now that her Mitch McConnell
um other Senators other members of
Congress were doing all that they could
do to try to get Donald Trump to call
this off and try to get them to leave
and the the actual Tick Tock of it all
to the end where he did tweet and his
supporters were like oh well he said go
home it is almost like he's a cult
leader and they were listening and
hanging on his every word as if they
were orders and it seems that way what
do you make him yeah I mean here's the
thing this was the only moment of you
know I mean obviously we heard from
people like Mitch McConnell and Kevin
McCarthy and we saw those though that uh
those videos of them when they were
doing the impeachment and they gave
their testimony to say this was
completely his fault he is responsible
you know obviously that was after the
fact in which they voted not to impeach
him how how convenient but it is
something to say like you saw the tick
tock of those events that happened right
they're calling the governor they're
calling these people they're calling the
mayor they're trying to get as many
resources as they can in order to get
the actual backup that they need to help
kind of facilitate this this
complete mess this [ __ ] show that was
happening you know I mean Nancy Pelosi
called it uh cleaning up the literal and
figurative poo poo you know that was
going on because we know they were
smearing [ __ ] on the walls because
that's the type of cult that Trump has
and to see that Tick Tock happen like
this is I thought this was an amazing
play by them to show them to say like
look bipartisan was actually there was
actually a bipartisan attempt here by
both people like Mitch McConnell Chuck
Schumer Nancy Pelosi they were all
working together to try to fix this
situation and clean up this this mess
that Trump had facilitated that he had
instigated his followers to show up to
the Capitol and break in so I think that
people should be clipping and sharing
this spreading this as much as possible
because it completely debunks this
narrative that Republicans have they're
like oh well Trump requested uh armed
resources to show up at the Capitol but
Nancy Pelosi said no it's actually I
mean we knew it was was false completely
but also this shows you definitive proof
that Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer Mitch
McConnell all these other people were
working together
to help clean up what Trump had created
well Gabe um I'm watching here to see if
there's anyone uh else in the wings
that's going to speak here but while we
wait I have I have someone with us Lee
McGowan politics girl
um I'm gonna go to her first and then I
also have Dr Rachel bittickoffer in the
wings here and we also have a few other
commentary for our panel again
um everyone if I cut out to uh someone's
speaking it's because I'm paying
attention uh to the microphones that are
outside the committee rooms but let's go
to Lee McGowan Lee McGowan a politics
girl podcast how how are you Lee
oh I'm terrible Tony that was so
depressing I mean I honestly I I felt
legitimately weepy multiple times during
this I
I can't believe that this happened and I
can't believe it is still carrying on
you know what I mean you see it laid out
like that and how it was all pre-planned
how it was all even prior to the
election but then on top of that just
seeing all the people that knew that
Donald Trump was lying because they
themselves had told him that
he hadn't won that the um his lawsuits
were failures that there was nothing
about Dominion that made any sense and
yet those people still allowed him to go
on television and keep saying that it
was a stolen election keep saying it was
a lie keep saying everything that he
said which not only led to the sixth
but has carried on for the last two
years we have legitimate people running
for office today
that are saying the election was stolen
we have people running for Secretary of
State to to certify the votes that say
that Donald Trump was telling the truth
we have people running for AGS that say
that the big lie is real and and I can't
believe the amount of people that not
only knew Trump was blatantly lying but
have allowed that lie to continue to get
air for the past two years even after
the tragedy of of 1-6 it's just
nauseating to me
I I can't agree with you more that it is
nauseating to watch what happened to our
democracy and how the January 6 select
committee has laid out The Tick Tock so
well
um for the American people to see hey
your democracy is at risk it's not
something that you should take for
granted it is something that you have to
work for because there are people who
want to destroy it
um for whatever reason but in this case
the reason was that Donald Trump the
president at the time wanted to remain
in power what do you make of the
committee
um requesting a subpoena and doing their
referrals at the end
well I think the committee is doing
exactly what they're supposed to do I
mean I think we have forgotten how
government is supposed to work I think
we've forgotten what government looks
like the committee is functioning the
way our government was set up to
function they are cooperating they are
coordinating they are doing their due
diligence even watching them at the very
end there going through
the formality of taking a formal vote
the formal recording of the votes it's
not just the eyes have it
Liz Cheney said I need to have a formal
vote and they went through each person
and they did it in the very specific old
schools
formal way that you're supposed to run
government we have forgotten that
government isn't just a bunch of people
who get five-minute news Clips on Fox
News and don't actually do their job but
just try to get sound bites on TV or
Burns in or or just try to get
themselves heard or try and up their own
um personality uh this is how
government's supposed to work we did the
work we went through hundreds of
thousands of documents we had even when
you see the pictures of the the
witnesses being
um is spoken to whether it's from Liz
Cheney from her home or the lawyers that
were in the room you see them they've
got all this paper laid out in front of
them they've taken meticulous notes they
are talking to the witnesses and they're
trying to unfold an entire story that is
how law order is supposed to work that
is what it's supposed to look like it's
not all fireballs and lies it is
formal responsible work in order so yes
it might seem dramatic to ask for Donald
Trump to uh be subpoenaed by this
committee but it's not this is exactly
the next step this is who you would have
to if you're going to be as they said
fair and thorough and give a full
context of what happened they need to
hear directly from Donald Trump so they
are doing The subpoena in front of the
American people so they can see it's not
behind closed doors it's not a bunch of
Democrats making a plan they're doing it
formally so that the American people can
see that this is the way it has to go
and this is the next person they need to
talk to and they also said you know
they're going to recommend a number of
criminal referrals which they didn't
have to do and they don't need to do and
the doj doesn't even need to take up and
then they're going to make a bunch of
recommendations to Congress for new
legislation so this can't happen again
well I think at a bare minimum uh
government should be good at doing that
stopping uh coup attempts on the
government that it's trying to protect
you you would think that would be a
pretty low bar here
um well it's never happened before I
mean this none of this has ever happened
before I I've been trying to monitor the
channel That is on I call it fraud
social
um they refer to it as true social
um Donald Trump's social media account
to see if there is any kind of reaction
and um he can't help but uh just re
repost things
um he's not giving any reaction to this
he was almost 18 hours silent
um
it's it's very telling today where we
have a at the the meeting that we watch
the hearing that we watched and then
across the street there is a trial going
on a criminal trial for seditious
conspiracy of The Oath Keepers with the
the leader Stuart Rhodes
um and some of these messages back and
forth from the Secret Service the Secret
Service now we know because of today's
hearing new in advance that The Oath
Keepers had a qrf which is the stash of
weapons that they stored across the
Potomac Secret Service did know about
that
um do you think that that is why
um they didn't really want to postpone
this because these two things are
intersecting the criminal trial and this
public political hearing what's your
take on that
do you mean that they didn't want to
postpone this hearing well they they
postponed it because of Ian
um and and I I believe that they really
didn't want to do that but they had to
um because of they needed all hands on
deck for the response to the hurricane
um but what do you make of this
crossword where the criminal trial meets
the the public American political trial
as it were in the January 6th select
hearing well I mean listen uh
unfortunately the two things intersect
more than we want them to right we're
seeing the people in we just watched the
hearing and the people that all took the
fifth uh were also all surrounded by uh
proud boys and Oath Keepers right you
got Roger Stone taking the fifth
surrounded by proud boys and Oath
Keepers you've got General Michael Flynn
taking the fifth surrounded by proud
boys and Oath Keepers the proud Boys
North Keepers were there from day one
they are a huge part of this story you
know
um Oath Keepers were standing by if
POTUS needed assistance after you know
if he was going to invoke the
Insurrection act these guys are all
connected whether the case is going on
across the street or not is irrelevant
Justice they're we're not putting
together a TV show here it happens to be
on TV but this is Law and Order it
happens you know things don't happen the
way we want them to happen they don't
happen in time the the January 6
committee I'm sure they wanted to do it
to be efficient but they also have to
tie this all up by a certain point
because they're going to lose two of
their members come January right so uh
Liz Cheney has been uh defeated and Adam
kinzinger is stepping down so uh they
have to finish this all up before those
two people are no longer in Congress so
there is a time limit on this and
um
and if I were them I would want to do it
before the election
um the January 6th committee doesn't
fall into the same jurisdiction as the
doj in that they can't talk about
certain things at a certain time before
the election they're just doing a
congressional hearing so a congressional
hearing can happen at any time and the
fact that just happens to coincide with
The Oath Keepers across the street
you know where it's not just the way the
cookie crumbles right just the way the
cookie crumbles I mean they're all
connected but I don't think they
deliberately did it to coincide with
that no I I wasn't saying I just the
actual imagery of it to me that's gross
it's all gross I mean listen picture of
the imagery of Justice itself it's a
scale right it's supposed to be a scale
that's balanced for justice the imagery
of having these corrupt men on one side
of the street who also happen to be
white supremacists and then what's
happening uh with the hearings and
knowing how much they are weighted
equally those two things those groups of
people are on both sides it's repulsive
and our country should be repulsed
there's no one that should be watching
this today and not thinking oh my God we
came so close to losing and if we think
this can't happen again we are kidding
ourselves because all these people
learned was how to do it better how to
beat the system there were just that
many people still in place who were
willing to uphold the law
um and
Donald Trump or whoever is in charge
won't make that mistake again and
clearly there are an extraordinary
amount of people especially an
extraordinary amount of Republican
sitting leaders right now who are
perfectly willing to turn a blind eye to
all of the shenanigans if it kept them
back in power and it's it's such a
disappointment and it's something we
have to fight so hard against well and I
think you put it in one word it is
really gross
um so I I appreciate
right I know that's a small small nugget
there but it is it is uh lee thank you
for joining us I appreciate you coming
after the hearing it seemed very long
but it came to an abrupt end um on on a
on a very
strange note that the former president
United States is being subpoenaed by a
select committee because he tried to
overtime overturn the government so Lee
thank you for joining us
hopefully we talk to you very soon thank
you bye everyone we're I'm I'm still I'm
still waiting to see if there's anyone
coming to the microphone it doesn't
appear that there is I want to bring in
Brett my zealous real quick though uh
Brett I I'm I'm monitoring this here and
I think it's kind of telling that that
committee members are not going to the
microphone I think it's very telling
that they're not speaking out they they
made their statement today at the very
end and boy when I said it was a Cheney
drone strike
um it was very precise in how they did
that operation at the very end with
those ending statements and then the
vote what did you make of it yeah I
think you know when you're doing these
events like the January 6th hearings I
think you have the political component
you have you know the the actual doing
the work of it but you also have a
messaging sort of perspective that you
have going on so I think right now the
committee wants to leave people with
what they just saw there on the
committee you know they want to lead
people with the subpoena and have that
be what's uh what's being talked about
I'm sure there are committee members
going around right now to some of the
news networks and speaking to them about
other things but I think that's the news
that they want to leave everybody with
and it was just really at the end of the
day
um you know a hearing that meticulously
went through a lot of the things we
already knew and really emphasized how
this was a premeditated attack and that
the premeditated attack was led by
Donald Trump himself and I think that's
just important and I think that's why uh
that's why the committee kept using the
word premeditated over and over and over
again and the bombshell clip of this
hearing that everybody will be speaking
about for a very long time I think is
that clip that we saw of speaker Nancy
Pelosi Senator Chuck Schumer Mitch
McConnell and others and how frantically
they were on that day of January 6th
talking to DOD talking to doj speaking
with local Governors calling vice
president Pence doing everything they
could on January 6th in order to try to
stop the chaos and stop the violence
while they were in the midst of all that
and I think it's just such a stunning
contrast to some of the clips we've seen
of some of these other Republicans who
try to act like they're tough guys out
there and notably I'm thinking of the
clip of Josh Hawley who was seen running
away in a panic from everything and just
I would love to see you know a side by
side of Holly running away while you
have Nancy Pelosi there kicking ass
doing everything in her power to try to
end the chaos end the violence and the
attacks on the police officers and I
think it's speaks volumes as to what was
going on and it runs so counter as well
it runs so counter to all these fake
narratives and all the gaslighting that
Republicans have been incessantly saying
every single day every single week what
they've been putting forth at these
Trump rallies I mean hey even in the
last Trump rally Marjorie Taylor green
had the nerve to blame Nancy Pelosi for
January 6th you cannot watch this clip
that we saw today of Nancy Pelosi and
not just say Marjorie Taylor green is a
Despicable liar and a traitor to this
nation and anybody spreading that kind
of gaslighting and propaganda which is
very kind of Russian in the style of
propaganda they pulled a page right from
the Putin Playbook accuse others of what
which you are guilty it is disgraceful
it is anti-American and we need to see
consequences for these people for the
Marjory Keller greens of the world
that's why it's important that we all
get out and that we have to take action
ourselves and and vote and make sure
that these people denying reality and
denying this terrific terrorist attack
on our country don't have any power
I couldn't agree more about getting out
the vote because folks that's the whole
point of this select hearing is to arm
you with the information for you to act
because we will wait for long periods of
time for the Department of Justice to do
its work it does take a long time to do
that work and to make those cases and to
bring them into court like you're seeing
across the street today with The Oath
Keepers and I think it is so important
that people understand that just like
Lee said that is the work of government
that is the work of the committee is to
bring it to you the American people let
you have the information and then you
get to decide you get to take action and
that action is to lean into democracy
and actually engage in democracy and use
your ballot
um Brett speaking of democracy
how how do you think that this ends with
this subpoena with Donald Trump
um because we we know we know he's going
to go kicking screaming he's going to be
a little man baby about this subpoena
there's no question it is Donald J Trump
um but do you have any kind of sense of
will he actually sit down I mean I mean
does this just seem like it could be
just theater from the committee or do
you think this is a serious issue where
they are going to push this what do you
think of this you know I'll be honest I
would love to get Ben's expertise on
this because you know he's the attorney
and so I'm curious to get his thoughts
um I certainly think just the way I see
it as a Layman as being a more symbolic
maneuver
um you know of of great import and maybe
this will have an impact on the way the
Department of Justice handles the case
especially in regards to obstruction
depending on how Trump handles this but
we all know how Trump is going to handle
this right it's going to be the same way
he's going to try to threaten
retaliation and lawsuits and delays and
frankly there's not that much time left
um for this committee to be running as
is as Lee mentioned they're
automatically losing two members and
it's important that if we do want this
committee to continue that we hold the
house and so it's important that
everybody gets out and votes but I think
you know we will see this process play
out in the legal space I would love to
get you know Ben's opinion on I know Ben
will be working on a breaking news
report right here on the Midas touch
Network that you'll be able to see
shortly here on YouTube that will
explain exactly you know how all that's
going to play out but you know Trump
today had a very very very very very
horrible day which means that it was a
very good day for justice despite you
know how how just sad and
heart-wrenching it is to to see that
footage and those text messages Donald
Trump had a bad day so that's a good day
for the United States of America for
those who have only been plugged in and
tuned in to this hearing it's important
that we tell you some of the other news
that came out of the United States
Supreme Court the United States Supreme
Court rejected Trump's bid to restore
the special Masters access to the
classified documents seized from
Mar-A-Lago from the documents that he
stole uh it was unanimously denied by
the Supreme Court Clarence Thomas had
referred Trump's appeal to the the
entire court and the court just rejected
it outright didn't even give it the time
of day so I think that is huge news as
we go forward the doj investigation
there is has continued to heat up in a
huge huge huge way and that's a massive
national security threat what Donald
Trump has done to our country there and
so I think we're going to continue to
see more things there Trump is really
getting to the end of his rope there
with the investigation in terms of the
legal Maneuvers that he could do and
meanwhile these kind of delay attempts
they they didn't really even work to
delay things all that much because the
Department of Justice was able to get
access thanks to the 11th circuit backed
all the documents that they needed in
the first place so you know he tried to
delay it didn't even work and even in
the face of that the Supreme Court
rejected him flat out I know there were
people concerned because it was
submitted to Clarence Thomas and that's
why you got to watch the Midas touch
Network and Ben's breaking news alerts
because Ben told you not to worry about
that I want everybody though if if you
do like this coverage make sure that you
subscribe to the Midas touch Network
just hit that subscribe button right
below it's easy it's free I want to make
sure you also go to the Tony Michaels
YouTube channel Tony has been putting on
an incredible show right here so head on
over go to Tony Michaels subscribe to
his podcast subscribe to his YouTube
channel and if you love this broadcast
you could support Independent Media in
two ways you could hit that dollar sign
I think it's they may have changed it
actually but there's a way to chip in
next to the YouTube chat just hit that
button Super Chat
um support independent media coverage
like this and you could also go right
now to patreon.com Midas Touch it's
patreon.com Midas Touch we got all these
great tiers and ways that you could get
involved and each tier offers great
bonuses and exclusives and there's even
an option for you yourself to become an
honorary producer of the Midas touch
podcast which is pretty cool and you're
supporting Independent Media you know
these hearings I I like to remind people
that we don't simply take you know know
steal a feed from these hearings of
other people we have our own officially
licensed feed and cameras that are in
the rooms during these January sixth
hearings and so any support that you
could give to this network is greatly
appreciated and and Tony you're just
running such a such a great show here uh
I appreciate it I appreciate it it is it
is thanks to um Gabe Sanchez as well
he's he's not in the green room right
now he's he's he's in a special bunker
somewhere we put him in a it looks a
little bit like he's in witness
protection it happens sometimes you have
to do that uh I I will tell you Jordy
will probably want me to mention the
real member shirts again because to
remind everyone not just for the The
Branding in the shirts of November but
as you said before row row row revote it
is so important that we get out and we
win the house so go to store that
minustouch.com store dot Midas touch.com
for those shirts also Brett I've got
this great shirt store.d Tony
michaels.com this thing is flying off
the shelves the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
it's it's going like hotcakes and
speaking of a shirt that we had today I
want to bring in uh David bender and
Brett can you join us for just a little
bit or D are you um are you crunched
yeah I'll join you guys for a couple and
then I'm gonna go start preparing for
our podcast if you watch right here on
the Midas Touch YouTube channel tonight
at 5 p.m Pacific 8 P.M you start to come
back right here we'll do a full recap of
the hearings do full legal analysis of
the Supreme Court's uh Trump denial
which is massive news we'll talk a
little bit about the Alex Jones case and
more so go check it out at the Midas
touch podcast make sure to subscribe to
the minus touch audio podcast as well
well I got I've got uh Ben and David
Bender here we want to get uh Ben's
legal take on it but I want to get
David's
um
strategic take from the politics in but
then I want to go to you first let's go
to Ben first Ben what what do you make
of the subpoena what's the legality of
it Brett Brett made a big call to you
said hey Ben get on the podcast or get
on the that feed here and give us your
legal take so what do you make of it
well I think they obviously have the
right to issue subpoenas ultimately as
we've seen before when it comes to uh
Mark Meadows when it comes to some of
the other individuals or or Steve Bannon
um Peter Navarro the determination on
whether to prosecute for not responding
to this subpoena will be a determination
for the Department of Justice to make
which is an important distinction that
the January 6 committee does not have
that criminal uh uh Power to actually
indict itself
um but it sends an important message you
know here you have someone like Trump
who's out there ranting and raving on
his failing social media platforms and
issuing these despicable statements and
the and here you have the January 6th
committee saying okay
let's let's hear from you you wanna you
wanna speak to us we're ready to hear
from you and the steps that we'll follow
is inevitably my prediction is is that
Trump is going to assert every objection
and every privilege and try to litigate
the heck out of it uh the January 6
committee as long as it remains
constituted is going to uh fight it and
um and ultimately uh they will it will
come out in favor of the January 6
committee because they have the right to
have this information I mean Trump's
potential basis of objection is to the
extent he wants to assert an executive
privilege as we all know executive
privilege doesn't lie with uh former uh
Executives the executive privileges with
Biden who is not asserting the executive
privilege on Trump's behalf another
additional Factor Why executive
privilege wouldn't apply is that there
would be a waiver Trump talks about it
all the time on his failing social media
platforms and to anybody who would
listen so so his claim of an executive
privilege or an attorney-client
privilege or whatever would fall would
fall flat we have a federal district
court judge already in the central
district of California who's found that
Trump and East men were engaged in a
coup in search of a legal Theory right
so he's already found that crime fraud
exception and so here the ultimate
determination of criminal liability will
lie with the Department of Justice what
the Department of Justice is going to do
literally as those hearings were taking
place today we got news that these
Supreme Court rejected Donald Trump's
emergency
application trying to overturn with the
11th circuit did and turning back those
classified records so literally while
you had the panel here the January 6th
committee panel voting 9-0 to subpoena
Donald Trump you had the Supreme Court
essentially voting 9-0 uh denying Donald
Trump's emergency application so he's a
double loser at the same time but I
mentioned that because there's a lot on
Merrick Garland's plate you know and
he's handling it masterfully like and
I've been saying this from day one about
how Merrick Garland has been building
this case Brick by Brick as mentioned in
today's hearing let's not forget as well
that there is an oath keeper trial a
terrorist oath keeper trial that the doj
is currently Prosecuting and at the same
time last week while that oath keeper
trial is taking place there's a guilty
plea from one of the leaders of The
Proud boys who pled guilty to seditious
conspiracy and said Enrique tario and
others were engaged in this conspiracy
with us in addition to the hundreds and
hundreds of other convictions that
Merrick Garland has been has gotten and
so Merrick Arlen and the doj is
ultimately going to have a decision as
this process plays out as Donald Trump
inevitably is going to obstruct and not
respond on to this subpoenas we all know
that's likely what's going to happen are
they going to bring criminal contempt
charges but remember what the ultimate
penalty is for criminal contempt charges
criminal unfortunately on the criminal
contempt charges for not responding to a
subpoena from Congress is still a
misdemeanor each count is punishable by
one year so Steve bannons who's going to
be going into sentencing this month in
the next week or so he faces one year
for each of the two counts for his
criminal contempt Peter Navarro's trial
I think is November 17th for his
contempt of congress that would be the
charge if Trump doesn't participate but
look Trump's got a lot of other bigger
criminal worries as well with what's
going on with his stealing our
classified records and the broader
criminal acts regarding January 6th but
this is another lever that ultimately is
going to be available to Merrick Arlen
when Trump obstructs this process
you know I hate to uh go to the phrase
um Trump seems really not in good shape
here
um it it really feels like there's a lot
against him here and uh David Bender I
I'm gonna ask you to keep it short and
here's why
we have someone in the wings here
waiting she is she knows Steve Bannon
she knows Trump and we just have too
many dudes on the screen here I think so
so David give us give us a recap here
okay really short and uh knowing Steve
Ben and annoying Donald Trump I I feel
for Jessica so let me let me say the
following first off to Ben's point just
now uh what we just saw was a parallel
construct to what nerick Arlo has been
doing Brick by Brick this committee has
laid out a legal case going from the
bottom up all the way and has handed
Merrick Garland their work and he's been
doing the same thing not in the public
view so I I completely agree with Ben
we're going to see Mary Carlin do the
right thing you heard me say it I I
think Poetic Justice would be to
announce it on January 6 2023 but I
think it will be sometime between the
election and other the new year right
after the new year so that's that's one
takeaway from today of course the big
question is how is Trump going to play
this
and if he were rational and this is I
think something you should ask Jessica
if he were rational in any way he
wouldn't get near this
but he's not
and we know that and we know he loves
television he loves to see himself and
he thinks he can take them on and Bully
them down which has been his entire life
he may just take that leap
uh and I I think it's a brilliant
strategy on their part to call him to
either do it uh because he's crazy or
not do it and then look like a coward
either way it was a winning move for
them to subpoena him and good on this
committee they wrapped it up exactly as
they've done every single one of them
and nine to nothing uh twice in baseball
season is a doubleheader sweep so that's
it well there you go and and Jessica
um
Jessica
the other thing about the ending here
that we that we watched is we watched
Liz Cheney
a Republican
a conservative
someone who cannot be confused with a
liberal Democrat
a woman absolutely
laying this out at the end there
and I think that moment just as David
says basically is almost game set match
in the select year in bore Donald Trump
because he's stuck in a in between Iraq
and a Cheney here
yeah Cheney Cheney really hit it home
what was so beautiful to acknowledge as
this hearing was going on today is the
active criminal investigations that are
underway now we again heard um the
raffensberger call I need 11 780 votes
and we can all take comfort in knowing
that Bonnie Willis has a grand jury
impaneled in Fulton County Georgia that
investigation is underway
um I do think to answer David Bender's
question
um am I familiar with their legal legal
Shell Games absolutely I've been playing
them or I've been on the receiving end
of them for five years
um I filed my first NDA lawsuit in 2018.
they moved us around from Forum to Forum
to Forum thought they could wear me out
thought I would walk away and go away
but three years later we invalidated
that non-disclosure agreement in court
which they never saw coming and was
absolutely beautiful and all it takes is
sticking to it sticking on the side of
Truth not moving not being distracted by
their constant
obstruction and you know look over here
gaslighting projection just staying the
course staying focused and I think the
committee has really laid the groundwork
for the doj to follow this path
um this is and we're back today on
January 6 crimes but of course we have
the whole classified document uh
investigation so these I think these two
are really you know these two paths are
coming coming
um
the criminal the criminal indictments
are coming for Donald Trump I really
really do believe that
um but one thing that I I started off
today talking about I want to rap back
to this point I know Brett has mentioned
it I know you've mentioned it Tony
um Ben's mentioned it I think everybody
on the panel
just consider that this man that we just
watched once again all of his crimes and
full relief his wannabe authoritarianism
his flagrant criminality disregard for
the Constitution and rule of law
disregard for our foundation of freedom
is on the campaign Trail to this day
with Republican candidates he is
supported and defended by the Republican
establishment to this day this is the
Republican party everything you saw on
on TV today is the Republican party
because they refuse to distance
themselves from him they own everything
that he has done and
that is who you are putting in power if
you let them take control of either
house of Congress in the midterms this
is so critically important that we pull
out all the stops in the next 26 days
not let these anti-freedom
anti-democratic fascist forces take
control of either house of Congress this
is our moment and it is extremely
serious
lean into democracy absolutely lean in
and do the things that you're supposed
to do which is democracy Jessica you're
against a hard break here right
in about five minutes okay well I want I
want to say thank you for joining us
everyone loves Jessica Denson uh on the
commentary panel Jessica
follow Jessica on Twitter at Jessica
denson07 uh Jessica thank you so much
for joining us if I come back to you but
if I don't get time to come back here I
just I want to say thank you for being
here and and and spending time with us
on these on on these hearings it's a
wonderful wonderful to share share the
panel with everybody here with the
audience I've
um you know met such a wonderful
community Through Midas Touch and I
think you know what has been what has
been built with the Midas touch
Community is such a beautiful example of
what can be done when we just raise our
voices we just come together we just
amplify the truth and true stories
um we are extremely powerful and and it
is within our hands to save our
democracy so I am very grateful to be
here thank you so much Jessica and again
if it's you can stick around but if you
go I I completely understand
um but I want to go back uh to uh Ben
and David just a bit uh Ben because
um Jessica brought up some criminal
referrals
um and you noticed at the end there Liz
Cheney really ticked her a few what
seemed to be were going to be criminal
referrals that they were gonna give Mike
Flynn and a few others what what legally
do you see
uh these legal referrals coming to
well you know I I think that Merrick
Garland has been doing uh yeoman's like
effort and and been very work's been
like and I think Merrick Garland for
people who were worried that maybe he
didn't have it under control or what's
Merrick Garland doing I think you now
see that Garland gets it and as I've
always defined the Merrick Garland
prosecution in The Brick by group in The
Brick by Brick you know first he kind of
had these you know kind of like the
shamans and kind of the the kind of the
clownish insurrectionist who didn't
necessarily do something violent but
trespassed right then you got to the
next tier which were individuals who
were actually violent then you got to
this seditious conspiracy you know
terrorist groups Oath Keepers proud boys
three presenters tier three and
Garland's been building up to that tier
four which I think frankly regardless of
the referral that Merrick Garland
has a Keen Eye towards those individuals
anyway which I consider the next tier
the eastmans the flynns the Jeff Clarks
you know the Sydney Powells the
giuliani's you know that tier is kind of
tier four and that's the final tier
before you ultimately make the decision
uh to indict Trump and the same way that
you have a proud boy leader uh taking a
seditious conspiracy plea and then
pointing the finger at Enrique atario
and others the next thing that I think
we'll see is will Enrique tario who by
the way was at the White House right uh
in right around Christmas time before
January 6 then was bragging about being
at the White House leading up to the
Insurrection and the tour that he got in
the special visit that he had will those
individuals will Jeff Clark will fascist
pillow guy will any of those individuals
then point the finger to Trump and so do
I think the referrals are important or
the potential for referrals by the
January 6th committee are they important
yes I think the Department of Justice
though has an under control regardless
but as we've been speaking about these
are two parallel important Services what
the January 6 committee is doing and
holding these hearings and making
recommendations pursuant to what these
congressional committees are supposed to
do is bring attention to the public make
recommendations ultimately make changes
in the law right to the Electoral count
act and other things that would you know
potentially further buttress efforts to
stop schemes like this and for people
engaging in this type of unlawful
conduct and just trying to stop it from
happening again so it's a very Dynamic
there's lots of moving Parts here but I
do think those referrals will be
important and I think in the final
opinion Union that we're going to see
from the January 6 committee report
they're going to have those referrals of
of who they want to see indicted well at
David Bender because I know you probably
got a lot to say about this but my
question is is that to me the referrals
seem more like a way for
um the committee to show the American
people hey we're taking this seriously
because as Ben says we know that Merrick
Garland is taking this very seriously he
has since the very beginning but do you
think that is more of a signal when
they're making these referrals to the
American people to say hey we hear you
and we know you want uh accountability
well it's sort of what Lee McAllen was
saying earlier that the formal vote
doing a record
each person having to cast the vote
individually as opposed to just a
consensus uh the eyes have it that's the
same thing that these referrals are it's
making it clear it's not binding but
it's it's making it clear that they
believe that there's culpability what's
much more important is that what Merrick
Garland has said you know and if we've
been paying attention as Ben has said
watch what he it's also Rachel Maddow uh
uh motto watch what he does uh and we've
seen his actions he said very little
although what he said is that he's
paying attention
and plainly he has paid attention to
what this committee has done I think
there's there are two things I want to
say and then I've got to jump but I've
got two things that that I think are
important takeaways that are not getting
the attention yet that they will uh one
is that they haven't finished going
through the Secret Service documents you
heard Pete Aguilar say we may well be
calling other Witnesses not necessarily
in public but we're going to be taking
other testimony based on the stuff that
we're finding out and clearly there's so
much of that they didn't have time to go
through all of it they're going to keep
doing that up through the election and
Beyond this committee will exist all the
way
hopefully it'll exist in the next
Congress if the if and when the
Democrats hold the Congress but
regardless they're that secret service
information is going to yield a treasure
Trove of more information I think people
like Tony onorato there's reference to
people who have been obstructing the
work of this committee are in the hot
seat today because that's who they're
talking about they're talking about the
people who were trying to undermine the
committee's work itself and the Secret
Service documents are going to show that
uh so I I think there's a lot more
coming from the committee in its final
report which will come after the
election
but what we do know today is they've
thrown down the gauntlet they put the
ball in Donald Trump's Court
and as far as I can tell he usually
dribbles
well David
you you put it uh always in such the
best way
um being in this business for so long it
it gives you that ability and I want to
thank you for joining us as I thanked
everyone else because it's been so
special this may be our last one Atlanta
no no no no no no no no we'll we'll be
back there's a lot more and there'll be
indictment day yeah there you go there
you go
let me let me go celebrate everyone to
subscribe to the Midas touch Network and
follow these campaigns through the next
26 days on the Midas touch Network
because we have to stay together as a
community we have to win these elections
and on Election night hey I you know if
there's coverage call me I I you know I
enjoy talking about election nights well
you know you know you're always welcome
here Mr David Bender this is uh not
farewell this is uh
it's it's just bye bye Donald it is
thank you thank you very much David
Bender for joining us you too Jessica we
we love having you Jessica do you have
any one last words before you have to
before you have to jump
I just realized I I left something out
of my midterm rant that that is David
David would back me on this if he were
still here this is so so serious what we
saw today was a truthful exhibition of
of facts of evidence it was Justice the
exercise of Justice on display
if the Republicans take even the house
just the House of Representatives
understand that they will impeach Joe
Biden they will impeach Merritt Garland
understand that this projection
gaslighting inversion of justice and a
re-living of the trauma of the Trump
years is coming
if Republicans take the house
I'm gonna if you're following me on
Twitter I'll retweet some of the
competitive house races I I know I'm I'm
I have shifted from my drum beat of
Donald Trump must be indicted which is
not not gone that still absolutely must
happen to the focus of the next 26 days
and I think there's a lot of attention
that the national media gives to the
Senate races but these house races are
so important I will retweet the link to
some of these competitive house races
even if you think you're in a you know a
definitively blue State
um you know we're here in California
there's some extremely important house
races right here in California they're
in Oregon they're in States all across
this country and you can get involved
and help
Democrats hold the house keep democracy
on its track don't let it derail in 2022
this is so crucial
um so that's my final word well thank
you again Jessica for joining us I I
always appreciate having you here
um always come back and if we have a big
celebration for election night or
something or our indictment day
um I you're welcome as always as always
thank you Jessica thank you uh Ben
myzealous
um I I don't know how much time you got
left because I'm going to end this with
uh my co-host Gabe Sanchez and and one
of our favorite it's not Tuesday see
what happens a lot of times is we have
Tuesday with Texas Paul it's Thursday so
I'm gonna bring in Texas Paul and Gabe
Sanchez but I want to give you one last
chance is there anything that we missed
here because I know there's so much one
one thing I want to ask you about is
they were practicing they called Rona
McDaniel the chair of the RNC and said
hey you know what we want to do we want
to have a coup practice we want to
practice this fake State electors thing
what did is is this illegal is this a is
this a crime I mean come on they're
they're they were gonna practice the
coup what it's just like my court or I
can't figure this out what was that the
crime
it's a crime the fake elector slate
issue is a crime uh submitting
fraudulent electors and practicing the
submission of fraudulent electors is a
crime it's actually a widespread
conspiracy of how it was actually going
to go down right because for the
electors to be coordinated as such the
fake electors it relied upon the
objections of the Maga Republican
extremists in the Senate and Congress to
object to delay with the ultimate idea
that they wanted vice president Pence to
reject the actual electors that were
certified and say the following wow look
at all of these objections that we got I
guess this is a dispute oh wait what's
this I've got the real electors over
here oh Georgia 16 electors for Trump
trump wins Georgia uh oh we got the
electors from Michigan oh look we got
the ones from Arizona oh look that was
the plan right that's actually what they
were good it was that's what and then
when Pence didn't do that Trump thought
that was the ultimate betrayal and then
he wanted to kill him and he tried to we
even we even seen the the
insurrectionists the people that were
breaking into and and as as Nancy Pelosi
put it smearing poo poo or pooping the
capital they were even saying Pence has
abandoned us yeah because he tweeted the
whole and let's not forget what what did
he abandon us did he abandoned us
because he didn't accept that the
objections the frivolous objections were
valid he was not going to view his role
as doing more than just signing off
um on the existing certified Electoral
College votes and he was not going to
unilaterally declare Trump as the king
and Emperor that's what they said was
the Betrayal that's why they wanted to
kill him that's why you had a violent
Insurrection I mean it's that simple
that's why to answer your question
directly you go what was that that was
the crime I want to say this before you
do your remaining thing I want to thank
you Tony I want to thank Gabe I want to
thank Texas Paul I want to thank Dave
Bender I want to thank Jessica Denson I
want to thank Michael popock I want to
thank politics girl I want to thank
everybody who was on this panel and most
importantly I want to thank everybody
who watched it who's still on YouTube
watching it right now you know the Midas
touch network is more than just this
sterile Network that's not the secret
sauce of what Midas Touch is and as what
Jessica Denson alluded to or what she
said directly rather is Midas Touch is a
community it is a unapologetically
pro-democracy community but more than
just even being a pro-democracy
community or inextricably intertwined
with being a pro-democracy community
where a community that uplifts each
other we are a community that looks out
for each other we are a community that
wants to see each other succeed to
spread positive messages to help each
other and so it always just warms my
heart when I watch these comments when I
see the comments on social media whether
it's the YouTube comments or the Twitter
comments or the Facebook comments or The
Tick Tock comments not just the ones
that say Hey great video Ben although I
think some of the videos I do are pretty
good but all kidding aside the best ones
are when I see people within the
community uplifting each other and then
telling me hey I reached out to this
person in my family I reached out to my
kids or my cousins or my co-workers or
my colleagues and I shared your videos
here and I shared your videos there
because being a part of this community
is also not passive and that's what I
love about the Midas Mighty it is an
active community of people who take
these videos who spread the message who
talk to family members who talk to
community members who talk to colleagues
and impart the importance of
pro-democracy this would not be possible
at all without the Midas Mighty
Community one thing I would say also is
if you're a member of the Midas Mighty
Community we're not funded by any
outside investors at all zero that's why
we're a hundred percent independent so
if you want to go and help out though
and and help support grow this network
one of the things you can do is check
out our new patreon website at
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com Midas Touch
patreon.com Midas Touch we have one
membership tier also where you could
become an honorary producer of the Midas
touch podcast and your name appears at
the end of the podcast there are other
tiers where you get postcards for me and
my brothers there's behind the scenes
photos and footage and exclusive
podcasts don't worry we still have all
the free content on YouTube on Twitter
on all our social media that's not going
away just the patreon around is just a
unique way to help grow this thing and
to help you know financially support
this entity where we don't have any
outside investors but no pressure either
way the best thing you can do is
retweeting and doing and just continuing
to spread the message
um subscribe to the Midas touch Network
now and you can also check out our merch
store we have the best unapologetically
pro-democracy gear out there at store
dot Midas touch.com we've got the famous
rovember shirts we got the row row row
your vote shirts we got the convict or
convict 45 shirts and more just nice
Midas Touch Gear with the hats what's
been so cool is when I'm out and about
now the Midas touch Community has grown
and become so prolific that when I see
people wear the Midas touch hats or I
see people wearing the Midas touch
shirts it's just such an incredible
feeling to see that so again check out
store.mitistatch.com Tony Gabe you do an
incredible job everybody also follow
Tony and Gabe on their YouTube channel
grow their YouTube channel just search
the Tony Michaels podcast subscribe
there Tony and Gabe do an incredible
incredible job I'm out thank you
everybody from the Midas I appreciate
you you being here and great pitch there
at the end great pitch there at the end
you know absolutely well we'll talk to
you soon my friend we'll talk to you
soon everybody we're gonna be we're
gonna be ramping it up here soon but I
want to bring in a couple people but
before I do that I want to say I
appreciate all of you being here because
again we couldn't do this coverage
without you watching and without you
being here just like Ben said this is a
community and we view it that way so
make sure if you are right now on the
Mindless touch networks EG Janet you hit
subscribe it's really easy just click
the button subscribe you definitely want
to hit the Bell notification rather
you're on the mind is touch Network
channel or my channel the Tony Michaels
podcast you don't want to miss a single
video that's coming out and you also
want to download every single episode of
our podcast the Midas touch podcast
legal AF and any podcast the politics
girl we have Mike Hopewell with Michael
Cohen there's so many podcasts and and
pieces of content out there that is on
that's free like like Ben said it's free
for you to do but you have to support
pro-democracy speech everywhere whenever
you can so go to the patreon page
patreon.com Midas Touch support them
there if you can or you can get you some
awesome merch at store.mindustouch.com
this is Gabe Sanchez this shirt that
we've got going on over here on our
store the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty that is
our saying at the beginning of our show
because we do a show every weekday
Monday through Friday two hours and this
this phrase appears at the front of that
show the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty in this
thing is absolutely going like hotcakes
it's hot hot just like the Midas Mighty
favorite Texas ball is hot hot hot guys
I wanted to end with with the the three
the three guys here because on Tuesdays
we have so much fun all right so why not
end it on a Thursday here
um is there anything that we missed
there was so much information and I was
watching the screen
um to see if anyone's gonna come to the
microphone and I got some notes saying
hey they're on networks everywhere and
that's just as I expected and what I
mean by that is they were not just going
to go into in front of a microphone
after this particular hearing and just
say whatever came to mind and just start
riffing off of questions they are going
to be very strategic especially at the
end with Liz Cheney
um doing the subpoena uh Gabe Sanchez
give us your take on that
yeah so I mean I I would totally agree I
think
obviously I the the camera view that we
have when they come outside of the
Committee hearing you know I think that
might potentially have limited kind of
uh broadcast in terms of who's showing
it
um but I but the one-off interviews
where they have specifically this person
whether it's Raskin or it's uh Zoe
Lofgren or it's Cheney or Benny Thompson
whoever it might be they're all probably
strategically going across I mean I
don't have a TV in front of me so I
can't tell you I'm in a Call Booth and a
wework right now so um I can tell you
that I I totally agree I feel like there
is a strategic kind of uh method to this
what they're doing right now is to is to
hit as many different people as many
it's not just the same person it's all
of them nine people from the committee
or or some variety of them are going to
go out and actually speak on this
because right now it is a night as David
Bender said it's a 9-0 loss on him on
this committee it's a 9-0 loss on just
the documents alone for the Supreme
Court so I think they're going to just
continue to nail in that Trump is both a
liar a narcissist some is a big whiny
baby that's trying to overthrow the
government because he lost a fair and
safe election
they're going to continue to nail that
in for the American public because again
this isn't a trial this is these are
just hearings that the committee has put
on and this is a this is if anything
this is the court of public opinion that
I said earlier and so what they're going
to do now is as we lead into 26 days I
believe is until the midterms we have
that much time until then to convince
the American people to attach the
Republican party with Donald Trump and
the downfall of our democracy and the
politics that we hold so dear to what
our values are right our core of what um
the the the United States of America is
and if we can do that then we can
accomplish the fact that we actually
have there is a way out of this [ __ ]
show there is a light at the end of the
tunnel it is not a train it is actually
a way to get out and I think what
they're doing right now is again
strategically going across in a variety
of different people pitching the same
thing and maybe a little difference of a
of kind of how they deliver it but
they're all going to continue to push
what the committee has has shown Us in
the past eight days and this culmination
of an up uh until today the ninth day to
say this guy is guilty he is the one
that should be held uh responsible for
inciting the violence and causing those
people to come in because he couldn't
take the fact that he lost Donald Trump
doesn't like to lose and I'm I'm
monitoring truth social right now and
the guy cannot stop messaging uh on on
fraud social to say oh well these people
held these documents and there's
precedent for this President and they're
shredding documents and this and this
and that old articles Old Post old
videos he's just the same old the same
old [ __ ] he's been it's the same old
stuff and he's on he's on Truth social
trying to bombard people with a bunch of
facts which they're just a bunch of not
facts they're just false narrative that
he's trying to spread to show the
American people he's like no no no look
guys I'm not lying I didn't try to do
this and and try to bury the lead which
is 9 0 he lost in both the committee
today from from the hand of Liz Cheney
as as Texas Paul said earlier and also
9-0 on the Supreme Court it was really
his last ditch effort to say hey guys
I'm not actually uh you know I'm not
responsible I should have these
documents their mind their mind their
mind and the Supreme Court was like
we're not even gonna look at that [ __ ]
so continue forward with how you guys
are proceeding right now and I think
that's you know that is what they're
doing on all you know again they're not
outside taking questions and recording
cell phones and all that stuff outside
of the doors they're all setting up
interviews and they're going to deliver
all their talking points to everyone for
the next probably a couple days I would
imagine it's strategic for sure Texas
Paul there's no question about that
um and at the end there and I I know I
know
um your prediction was a little off but
I think you're happy about about your
prediction being off here
um I think you're happy right I mean I
mean all offensive purposes this is a
good thing and like I said I you know
rather it has teeth and actual
consequences here or more it's to show
the American people people hey
um we are we are going to make sure that
that the that it's done up and there's
people are held accountable
yeah and you know this thing's been the
whole thing has been such an emotional
roller coaster I mean when it took place
everyone was you know angry I mean we
were just pissed off that they would
dare do this and then as we found out
how close they actually came to
succeeding I mean if they could have
just delayed that vote for a few days
they they would have succeeded Donald
Trump would have we would have had a
coup
they came this close to succeeding with
their coup and that was terrifying
and then we saw the committee
and everything that we've been seeing is
yeah it's it's it's it's not pretty to
look at but it leaves you hopeful
and you know then we had the elections
and and the primaries and yeah we're
gonna lose Liz Cheney and and yada yada
and that was kind of sad and
but now today
when you watch this today
I don't know man I it just left me proud
the whole thing just left me I have I
feel better today
about my country than I that I felt in a
long time
you know just its future prospects I
mean watching that you know yeah I was
laughing my ass up I think it was
fantastic that this came from Liz Cheney
Benny Thompson would have normally been
in a normal order of business would have
been the one to to do this but to give
it to Liz Cheney to do was just Justice
and yeah I laughed my ass off about that
but as I watched them take the vote
man I admit I I got the feels man I
really did it just it just hits you you
know it felt like you're gonna be okay
yeah we're gonna be okay we're gonna
we're gonna win this we're going to be
okay
um I the one thing I I didn't think they
were going to subpoena Donald Trump
because that gives them the opportunity
he won't just plead the fifth he's going
to draw this out and we only have until
January third with this committee that's
when you know no matter what happens
two people have already lost they lost
their primaries they're gone so this
committee cannot stay in this foreign
he did he sent out a couple tweets of
course going after the unselect
community but the new narrative the new
excuse he has is and this is I'm I'm
quoting him on Truth social right now he
said why didn't the unselect committee
ask me to testify months ago why did
they wait until the very end the final
moments of their last meeting because
the committee is a total bust that has
only served to further divide our
country which by the way is doing very
badly a laughing stock all over the
world
all these documents are mined and they
must give them back but they're all
planted like right they did ask you I'm
pretty sure there's been an open invite
for Trump to come to the committee and
speak there yeah no one else this is
about don't you dare come to this
meeting and speak it's they're 100 if if
Pence wanted to come there was an invite
for him if Donald Trump wanted to show
up since this thing is all it's the
Donald Trump hour is what this hearing
was and how he wanted to try to
overthrow the government and plot his
whole coup and everything he it's it's
about him he said he's like I want Fair
time he said about you know and during
the last hearings that we had he
complained about not getting Fair time
and not being able to speak no one's
denying him access to speaking we've I'm
pretty sure they've asked him if he
wanted to come forward he's rejected but
at the end of the day he's gonna can you
do complain say they were planted but
there actually has documents he's gonna
say he wasn't invited though it was all
about Trump jump anyway
he's he's going to try to
pivot The Narrative and say oh no no no
no it's their fault because they didn't
ask me to come they didn't say I was
invited
when at the end of the day that's not it
at all right we know the truth he's
upset that he doesn't have a platform
other than this fraud social to declare
a bunch of debunked lies in whine and
cry and splatter ketchup all over the
walls and try to choke you know uh
Secret Service with his tiny little
hands whatever it might be the guy is a
big baby and he's trying to
he's trying to you know reconstruct the
narrative to say oh well actually the
truth of it is this when we know it's
not and we've seen the evidence we've
seen the video we've seen the audio
we've seen the testimony it's not going
to work but he's going to continue to do
it obviously
well yeah Gabe but that's you know what
it's for I mean if you look at what he
was posting earlier it was uh you know
it was that [ __ ] about you know it
it's not true fake fake news I actually
won and this
all of this is just to keep the grift
going oh yeah he knows he's running out
of time but you know if there's one
thing I have to if I could give Donald
Trump a compliment I would say that he
is really really freaking good at
separating stupid people from their
money
well and that's what this is all that is
what this is all about think about the
narratives he put out there no I really
want I mean all the [ __ ] you was
reposting earlier no I really won and
then now this is you know oh I'm the
victim look at me I'm the victim while
he draws this all out for you know
as far as he possibly can to keep
holding these rallies he's going to keep
holding these rallies he's going to keep
taking money from these people I mean I
I would bet you that he's probably taken
half a billion dollars off these suckers
I I would bet you we have to remember
that you know he's got his save America
pack he also I'm I'm gonna do a what was
that on this but he uh he started a new
um a new uh Super PAC that was well he
started a new Trump organization too
Trump organization not not just two but
Roman numeral two as if the sequel was
any better than the original
organization itself but this guy will do
whatever he can to Pivot around and be
like oh actually here's my money and you
say he's probably got all this money
yeah he does he he does have a war chest
of money I think it's a hundred and some
odd million dollars right now with the
save America pack which is a leadership
hack which is different than a Super PAC
uh but the guy is is moving around funds
claiming it's going to be for this he's
going to help during the midterms just
like he said he was going to help during
the Georgia runoff but he didn't even
pay a cent the guy will grift whatever's
possible whether it's to form and build
up a war chest just for personal
purposes it's not going to be for a 2024
run it's not going to be for any of that
stuff it's for himself he is building a
a little safe haven for when he does get
in real big trouble whether the
indictment income and you actually have
to have a a
competent legal team because we know
that he doesn't right now as we've seen
from the the Trump Mar-A-Lago documents
case they're all just completely
incompetent
um
why I think in their news um the the CIS
or scice or whatever he actually joined
the special Master team apparently now
uh or something because because those
attorneys just weren't competent enough
so they had to get the one attorney
who's willing and he's the only attorney
that we know of that has actually been
paid he said I want three million up
front on retainer and that was the
biggest because in in the month of
August his that was the largest amount
it was
3.8 million I think they had spent on
legal fees and three million of that
amount came from just that retainer fee
for for that uh Chris Chris Keys yeah
and you know everyone's been joking but
it makes sense that Maga stands for make
attorneys get attorneys because we
watched as Christina Bob has disappeared
into the abyss of talking about Trump's
legal issues right now what was the
other one uh Haba Haba she's is she I I
haven't seen I haven't seen her later on
I mean Christina Bob you know she's
she's off rsbn doing all the Trump
rallies giving commentary saying I was
never a part of that even though her
literal signature is on the FBI uh I was
just getting coffee I was just getting
coffee there I was an actual attorney
actually as soon as the doj starts
opening up with indictments on this
January 6th stuff Christina Bob is in
deep [ __ ] she was at the Willard Hotel
she has been a part of this from the
get-go she is desperate desperate she's
gonna stay super tight to Donald Trump
because that is her only Lifeline right
now well that that is true and I think
that goes to David Bender's Point
earlier again there was so there was a
watershed of information today out of
this hearing
um Tony arnato is in a lot of deep [ __ ]
here
um and anyone tied to him or is on his
team is probably in a lot of Deep [ __ ]
they have a lot of criminal liability
now with what they were obstructing and
let me tell you something and I I can't
remember if Ben said this or someone
else said this today it might have been
Pope
obstruction is a charge and a crime that
the Department of Justice takes just as
seriously or more seriously than almost
any other crime other than murder or
killing individuals obstruction of
justice is something they take very
seriously and um Tony arnato is in a
hell of a lot of trouble if they find
the evidence that he was obstructing
justice
um he's in big big big big trouble you
know we we know tornionado is a liar
right we've seen it before and and it
goes even even more with with obviously
there was the Cassidy Hutchinson
testimony that we heard or in the
earlier ones about Trump having his
little baby tantrum in in the in in the
in the in the truck with them and trying
to choke out again the Secret Service
with the with his tiny little hands and
then Trump getting all upset and you
know we heard testimony about the
ketchup and the plate and all this stuff
very embarrassing stuff for a for a man
who declares himself as a stable genius
but you heard things from Tony ornado
and people inside the Secret Service
that was like we denied
this isn't true this never happened you
had Donald Trump Jr doing the his Don Jr
videos where he goes out and tries to
you know go after Biden all this stuff
but in this video he tried to say that
Cassidy Hutchinson was never in the
meetings was never around when we
literally have photos presented just
about her being there right I did a hip
with Meadows and every one of these
meetings well that's another good point
there's another nugget a video evidence
that Nancy Pelosi is not to blame here
she was the one who was working to try
to make this her Mike Pence uh Chuck
Schumer even Mitch McConnell was
standing there in the mix to try to get
someone to do [ __ ] something just
anything absolutely anything and I think
the most telling moment is when her and
Chuck Schumer are talking to Jeffrey
Rosen who was the acting attorney
general time because he didn't actually
have any anybody that was official they
were all acting
um and he was acting as president too he
was an acting president almost he was
pretending to be president but here's
the thing is when Chuck Schumer said
what the hell are you going to do about
this you it is your responsibility as
the leading law enforcement officer of
this country called him and tell him
tell him that you have to tell them to
stop it was very dulling
um that this narrative was absolutely
just shattered into a million pieces
with just a little bit of a video
evidence I mean tell me tell me that
isn't part of what just made you leave
today with with with some confidence and
a good feeling was watching watching
Nancy Nancy Pelosi out of everybody in
that room did you ever hear her voice as
though she was rattled or nervous nope
she was calm cool collected in control
she was naming our people okay we got a
couple this person we have to call this
person get this person on the phone she
was talking to the governor of Virginia
she's like okay commit to me say it in
my ear what you're doing I want to know
and then she put that phone down and she
said okay we have these assets moving
right now and I mean that is what a
leader does I mean she
I have to tell you I owe her a massive
apology
I was so for Tim Ryan becoming speaker
you remember that kerfuffle a couple
years back yeah I was like yeah let's
get some new blood in there and Nancy's
been great and this that and the other
I am so sorry I am so sorry watching her
cool yeah watching her cool demeanor
there was a there was a line in that
clip that I that I that I think really
at least it stuck with me and I'm sure
it did with a lot of people is the fact
that she was like they're going through
and they're kind of ran they're
ransacking and destroying stuff all you
know through our offices she's like that
I don't care about she's like I don't
care about that that doesn't matter to
me that's that's irrelevant the people
the people the matter the the the harm
and the safety as Schumer came in and
said that part is what care what I care
about right now I just need people to go
in and clear the [ __ ] show that is this
Maga cult and what they're doing right
she was like oh they got poo poo right I
mean they're smearing [ __ ] on the walls
like that's that's the type of people
they are but that's the type of person
she is where she's like I don't care if
they take my stuff they can steal my
males what they ended up doing steal my
computer whatever but what I care about
is the people inside right I care about
out the police officers that I'm
watching on TV right now be assaulted
for a friendly Capital uh Capitol Hill
uh tourist no no no no Gabe it was
antifa yeah yeah yeah yeah well but then
it was touristic they can't really
decide even to this day even Kevin
McCarthy again more information that
this that this committee revealed that
the cussing match again was confirmed by
a another person that conversation
happened so Kevin McCarthy if you're
listening to me you are a liar and you
are a coward because you won't just say
it just say what happened just say it
because now it's three people it's three
confirmations of that conversation uh
gentlemen I appreciate you joining us
but we're gonna have to ramp here soon
um just because we've been doing this
for five hours and the folks joining us
now have been here for almost all five
hours people are dedicated to democracy
and that's why we we love the Midas
touch Network and the Midas touch
Community the Midas Mighty so go ahead
and subscribe to the Midas network if
you're on their Channel now and if
you're not on on their Channel if you're
on our Channel or go over to our Channel
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google just search the Tony
Michaels podcast you can also follow us
at Tony Michaels pod on Twitter and
really you could do us a huge favor and
do yourself a favor because this shirt
is kick and ass I mean everyone loves a
shirt the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty we also
have it in hoodies a zip up Hoodie as
well you gotta check it out you gotta go
over there Texas Paul you've got a
YouTube channel where you're doing shows
over there go search Texas Paul's
Channel just search his handle there uh
Paul search TNT or or search TNT or
something got a little change coming
we've been we've been doing one show a
week and it's just gotten pretty popular
so what we're going to end up doing is
moving it to Tuesdays and Thursdays days
to follow the podcasts the guys podcast
so they could you know it'll you know
you guys were watching the podcast
though straight over to us we'll be
there you know what I mean keep keep it
rocking and rolling it's just been well
received so we're gonna do a couple
shows a week there is one thing I wanted
to throw out there one more props to Liz
Cheney if I got real quick about it
um what I was saying she
the way feds look at stuff like this she
is keeping this out of the doj's hands
for a reason
they are hitting everything they are
showing us all the ugly
the D the doj feds don't work that way
you know they they could have they could
they could have gone after Al Capone
Forever on every crime he ever committed
as soon as they got him on something
substantive they were done out
send them to jail move on and that's the
way feds work
she has made sure I want to give her
such props for this she has made laid
out so many [ __ ] crimes that Donald
Trump has committed
and they can't ignore it well you know
Sean handy likes to play him on a reel
and Gabe you know what it sounds like to
me as Texas Paul is is is doing pittance
he's he's really apologizing to Liz
Channing for for miscalculating this
afternoon no I'm just kidding Texas Paul
I I think I think he's he's completely
right on that
yeah I don't like Liz Cheney I don't
agree with Liz Cheney uh she's a Cheney
I never will but I will tell you she's
done an amazing job in this and and uh
you know hats off really I will tell you
Liz Cheney amazing Texas Paul
um he he apologizes for his thing his
his uh his prediction this afternoon and
you proved him wrong with a Cheney drone
strike because that's really
what I like about this Genie the most
right now is she is the best enemy of
the enemy of you know not my friend
whatever the phrase is right whatever
you mean my enemy is my friend yeah
she's right now she is the epitome of
that and she proved that today
um and and I really again I think with
the nine zero vote
on on both counts on both counts it just
shows you that democracy is real it is a
real living breathing thing and it's you
guys it's you out there that are hearing
our voices on this show for the past
five hours it's you you are the
Democracy so lean into it uh rovember is
coming it is coming so go to store that
Midas touch.com to get your favorite
rovember or row row row your vote design
but more importantly you have to get
engaged not just wear the message but be
the message and go do what democracy
Seas do best and that is Crush fascism
that is why they are terrified that is
why they are scared of you that is why
they're trying every single little
aspect and that's really what I my
biggest takeaway from today they were
willing to try anything and everything
no matter what the plan no matter what
the ski no matter what the conspiracy
theory no matter what the delusion no
matter how ridiculous the plan or the
the the it may have sounded they were
going to try it and they were going to
try to make Donald Trump King of the
castle even if he had to go down there
and do it himself that was the plan
everyone thank you for the coverage
Texas Paul thanks for joining us Gabe
thanks for joining us here on the Midas
Dutch networks coverage of day nine of
the January 6th select hearings guys I
know this might be the last one but
we'll have more broadcasts somewhere and
yeah Texas Paul you'll join us on
Tuesdays for Texas I'll be there on the
Tony Michaels podcast so don't forget to
go over and subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast to see on Tuesday's
Texas Paul but me and gay broadcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
you can also download every single
episode of the podcast everyone might as
mighty you are the best community out
there
thank you for joining us for all five
hours of the coverage today until next
time surf's up as I say on our show
Surf's Up [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]